Die.
I've had seven different passwords and they've got them all so far. They attack innocent people like an Internet hate machine. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 121, 121 heißt die Folge heute. Nein, sie heißt sie nicht, sondern so ist sie nur. Und heute geht es um das Internet im weiteren Sinne, und zwar in seinen Irrungen und Wirrungen, mit dem es uns regelmäßig das Hirn vernebelt. Die Rede ist von Memen, von so einem Effekt, der irgendwie neu zu sein scheint und ob das wirklich so ist, und was dahinter steckt, das will ich heute diskutieren. Und zwar gleich mit zwei Gästen auf einmal, nämlich mit Jens Ohlig und mit Christian Heller. Hallo. So, ihr wart ja schon mal bei CRE. Ihr seid ja jeweils, aber immer getrennt. Immer getrennt, genau. Das fiel mir auch gleich auf, deswegen dachte ich, fege ich euch mal zusammen, da ihr ja irgendwie so sehr unterschiedliche Ansätze verfolgt, dasselbe Thema zu verfolgen. Während Christian es eher, wie soll ich sagen, wissenschaftlich angeht.
Oh ja, genau.
Steht Jens voll in der Fanboy-Riege. Kann man so sagen, ja. Kreischende Mädchen, erste Reihe, New Kids on the Block-Konzert. Du bist dabei. Ganz genau. Du findest das super. Ich finde es natürlich auch, wie jeder Mensch, ab und zu mal nervig. Aber dann finde ich es auch wieder super. Ja, jetzt fragen sich natürlich alle, wovon reden wir eigentlich. Das ist eine gute Frage. Christian, du hast ja einen Vortrag gehalten auf der Republika.
Wie fandest du die eigentlich? Insgesamt? Oh, ich hatte viel Spaß.
Du reißt dich nicht ein in die Riege der Mäkler.
Na ja, wenn man jetzt nur auf das Konferenzprogramm fährt. Ich hatte auch so einige Veranstaltungen, in denen ich saß, wo ich dann eher etwas fade fand und wo ich dann wieder rausgegangen bin. Ich war aber allerdings auch sehr selektiv und habe mich auch bemüht, mich vor allem in die Sachen reinzusetzen, die ich spannend fand. Und davon abgesehen ist es aber halt auch ein großes Socializing. Und das hat sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Und da habe ich viele sehr spannende Gespräche geführt.
Das ging mir auch ähnlich. Ja, muss ich auch so sagen. Also manche Vorträge waren halt langweilig so, wie das halt manchmal so ist, aber eigentlich, ja, die Leute waren es halt, die es gemacht haben. Und das war insgesamt halt eine super Konferenz. Ist schon so ein bisschen auch ein Ort da, wo so das Internet zusammenkommt auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise, oder? Ich glaube, das ist auch dann so ein Punkt, wo wir später nochmal drüber reden müssen bei Memen. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Punkt, wo Internet-Kultur zusammenkommt. Oder Internet-Jugendkultur. Oder ja, früher waren halt alle Leute irgendwie gleich, die einen Akustik-Koppler benutzt haben und gehörten irgendwie alle zu einem Stamm. Und mittlerweile gibt es da mehrere. Da gibt es halt diejenigen, die das als Pop-Kultur konsumieren und gestalten. Und es gibt die Techniker und so. Und so erkläre ich mir das halt auch, dass da so, dass man da halt im Netz auch so Sachen las, so von wegen überflüssige Veranstaltungen und wer geht dahin. Es ist halt nicht für die... Ja, die Kursi-Koppler-Fraktion fühlt sich ein bisschen auf den Schlips getreten.
Richtig, genau.
Das wollen die in unserem Internet. Genau, genau. Wir benutzen das auch gar nicht richtig und was soll das? Das ging schon sehr früh los, dieser Effekt. Ich erinnere mich noch an die Zeiten, wo das Internet ganz neu war und man irgendwie jeden Monat mehr neue User hatte im Internet, als es bis dahin insgesamt gab. Und dann trampelten sie irgendwie die ganze Blümchenwiese tot. Das Usenet musste ganz schnell dran glauben. Und dann kam halt auch noch dieses komische Web. Und das war ja überhaupt schon sehr verstörend. Davon haben die sich nicht so richtig erholt, habe ich den Eindruck. Richtig. Ja, ist halt auch so. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt einfach mehrere Kulturen. Also ich habe das mal irgendwann so verglichen, dass ich gesagt habe, das ist so ein bisschen wie mit der Besiedlung von Nordamerika im Wilden Westen und so, wo dann halt am Anfang halt die Trapper und Fallensteller die Pfade irgendwie klar gemacht haben und dann immer wieder die Frontier nach Westen gezogen haben. Das waren halt so die Hacker und die Techniker und die Akustikkoppler-Leute und so. Aber irgendwann war dann halt auch der Punkt erreicht, wo es Städte gab da und Leute mal ins Kino gegangen sind oder ins Varieté und ihren eigenen... Straßenbahnen gab man keine Fallen mehr stellen muss. Und das ist, glaube ich, halt auch der Punkt, ja, der dann halt aus dem Internet einen Kulturraum gemacht hat. Und in diesem Kulturraum gibt es dann halt auch so was wie Meme, wo viele Leute dann halt auch vielleicht, die ganz, ganz lange schon im Internet sind, aber nicht in diesem Kulturraum Internet sind, ein bisschen fassungslos davor stehen, was da eigentlich gerade passiert. Das ist auch bei Techniken oder so. Also ganz häufig hört man halt bei Technologien wie Twitter oder sowas, dass Leute halt sagen, ich verstehe das alles nicht. Das sind aber Leute, die schon irgendwie 1989 oder so einen E-Mail-Account hatten, aber jetzt plötzlich sagen, sie verstehen Twitter nicht. Anscheinend ist es nicht ein technisches Problem, sondern eine Kulturleistung. Oder ein Generationenproblem? Oder ein Generationenproblem. Mit anderen Worten, das Internet ist auch nicht anders, als das sonstige Leben auch. Genau. Und das Internet ist halt auch jetzt vielschichtig. Also da gibt es halt nicht nur Nerds, sondern ganz unterschiedliche Gruppen. Ein paar davon liefen auf der Republik herum. Wir gehörten auch dazu. Als Vertreter von, ja, keine Ahnung, welcher Generation oder welchem Kulturkreis wir uns da zugehörig fühlen können. Ich fühle mich eigentlich immer noch in fast allen wohl, muss ich sagen. Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, ich verstehe Twitter. Ich verstehe Twitter schon irgendwie. Zumindest habe ich da keine Angst vor. Und ich denke auch, das ist irgendwie auch Quatsch. Man muss da auch jung bleiben und dranbleiben. Wo es dann allerdings immer ein bisschen schwierig wird, das ist ja irgendwie dann dieses Memeding, was ich schon angesprochen habe. Christian, du hast ja einen Vortrag gehalten auf der Republika zu dem Thema unter dem Titel Das egoistische Memekultur der Internet-Meme. Kannst du mal kurz mal anreißen, wo dieser Begriff eigentlich herkommt?
Der Begriff kommt aus einem Buch, was passenderweise das egoistische Gen heißt. Und dieses Buch ist ein Buch, grob gesagt, über Evolutionstheorie von Richard Dawkins, den man derzeit vor allem eigentlich dadurch kennt, dass er einen sehr großen, lauten Atheismus-Kreuzzug gegen alle möglichen Formen von Religion führt.
Atheismus-Kreuzzug ist schön hier.
Aber der ist halt schon seit ein paar mehr Jahrzehnten tätig und da kommt er halt eigentlich mehr aus dem Bereich der Evolutionsbiologie und hat halt ein Buch geschrieben und dieses Buch befestigt sich in sehr allgemeiner Weise damit, wie funktioniert so etwas wie Evolution bzw. wie könnte so etwas wie Evolution aufschlüsselbar sein in Begrifflichkeiten wie Mathematik, Spieltheorie und so weiter. Und er zeigt da so ein paar Dynamiken auf, nach denen sich so etwas wie natürliche Auslese und so weiter im biologischen Werden von Arten beispielsweise vollzieht und behauptet dann diese Dynamiken, die lassen sich auch auf andere Phänomene anwenden, also beispielsweise auf Kultur. Das heißt beispielsweise, dass ähnlich, wie sich bestimmte Eigenschaften von Tierarten meinetwegen über die Zeit unter bestimmten Umständen verändern, können sich beispielsweise auch bestimmte Eigenarten von Sprachen beispielsweise verändern. Die scheinen danach ähnlichen Dynamiken, ihre Wandlungsprozesse zu vollziehen. Und Ähnliches gilt halt für andere Phänomene, wie meinetwegen Ideen, Geschichte, Religion und dergleichen. Und konkreter gesagt hauptet er, dass es da bestimmte Muster gibt, die sich ähnlich resistent machen, beispielsweise wie sich auch biologisches Leben resistent macht, die sich reproduzieren, genauso wie sich biologisches Leben reproduziert. Und er nennt diese Muster halt Analogie zum Gencode, nennt er sie Mem.
Was sind denn seine Beispiele, also nennt er welche?
Ja zum Beispiel, schon genannt sprachlich funktioniert das ganz gut, das heißt beispielsweise gibt es einen Liedtext und der Liedtext, wenn er vorgetragen wird, geschieht es sehr schnell, dass da irgendwie ein Fehler an einer bestimmten Stelle passiert, weil beispielsweise, so wie das ausgesprochen wird, es schwer verständlich ist und es naheliegend da klingt dann ein anderer Text dort einzusetzen und dann untersucht er, wie sich dieser Fehler halt verbreitet. Das heißt, andere Leute hören wiederum das Lied vorgetragen und aufgrund der Umstände, meinetwegen der Akustik in einem Kirchensaal, kann sich dann dieser Fehler sehr gut ausbreiten. Und das vergleicht er dann halt damit, wie sich beispielsweise bestimmte Eigenarten in der Biologie verbreiten können. Oder halt ein anderes Beispiel sind für ihn halt Religionen und da kommt wahrscheinlich auch sein Kreuzzug, den er derzeit führt, her, weil er halt behauptet, bestimmte Ideenmuster können sich resistent machen, beispielsweise gegen so etwas wie Kritik und gegenüber Skepsis. Und das tun beispielsweise Religionen, weil sie halt in ihrem Ideengehalt immer mittragen, wer nicht an mich glaubt, der ist per Definition schon falsch und der muss beispielsweise Strafe befürchten, weil er ins Höllenfeuer kommt. Und das appelliert halt an die Psychologie in einer Weise, die es schwer macht, da noch so ein Apparat wie Skepsis gegen anzubringen. Und auf diese Weise macht sich Religion, in dem sie auch sagt, wenn du was Gutes tun möchtest, dann musst du mich weiter verbreiten zu etwas, was ich zu einem sehr potenten Meme gewissermaßen.
Also ähnlich wie in der Biologie, wo es halt darum geht, dass diejenigen, die am besten angepasst sind, Survival of the Fittest, dann halt auch die meisten Nachkommen produzieren, ist das dann halt auch bei diesem Gedankensplittern, Ideensplittern dann so, dass das, was am besten sich durchsetzen kann, dann sich halt auch letztendlich durchsetzt. Und natürlich, klar, Monotheismus ist einfach memetisch, genetisch mächtiger, als wenn es halt ein gleichberechtigtes Nebeneinander gibt. Und natürlich ist diese Idee, dass man halt geht hin und predigt allen Völkern, wie das irgendwie einige Religionen haben und andere wederum nicht, das ist dann halt auch gut für das Überleben dieser Idee, für das Überleben dieses Memes.
So ein Mem ist gewissermaßen kulturelle Einheit oder Idee, die sehr machtvoll darin ist, sich zu verbreiten und sich selbst irgendwie stabil zu halten.
Im Grunde ist das Internet halt auch eine Art Mem. Ich kann mich halt, wir haben das eben schon besprochen mit diesen Trappern und Fallenstellern oder so, halt noch an der Zeit erinnern, wo man halt wirklich Leuten auch noch erklären musste, was ist eigentlich ein Modem und wie kommt man mit dem Modem ins Internet. Und es gab irgendwann einen Punkt, ich glaube, der war so um 95 rum, aber weiß ich nicht so richtig, wo das plötzlich umgekippt ist. Und ich glaube, das kommt auch aus diesem Dawkins Buch, dieses Beispiel mit dem 100.
Affen.
Was meinst du, das ist umgekippt? Die Modems sind umgekippt oder was? Also, es gibt, glaube ich, in diesem Dawkins Buch dieses Beispiel mit dem 100. Affen, dass man Konservenbüchsen und Büchsenöffner auf einer japanischen Insel platziert hat, wo halt Affen lebten, und man konnte dann ab einem bestimmten Punkt halt sehen, okay, der erste kommt drauf, wie er die Büchse öffnet. Dann guckt sich das der zweite vom ersten ab, und dann kommt der dritte von denen ab.
So.
Und dann konnte man halt nachvollziehen, wer von wem was gelernt hat und konnte das auch protokollieren. Aber es gab irgendwann einen Punkt, wo das anscheinend, ja, in der Affenpopulation als Ganzes plötzlich da war, ohne dass man jetzt sagen konnte, der hat das von dem gelernt, und so geht die Kette, sondern plötzlich hatte sich diese Idee, wie benutze ich Werkzeuge, um Konservendosen zu öffnen, komplett durchgesetzt. Genauso das gleiche ist halt memetisch mit dem Internet passiert. Was heißt das? Man hat, man musste dann keine Werkzeuge mehr, keine Konservendosen auslegen? Aber es war halt nicht mehr so, dass der Einzelne drauf gekommen ist und der Einzelne das vom anderen gelernt hat, sondern irgendwie diese Idee, ich benutze Werkzeuge, um diese Konservenbüchsen zu öffnen, die hatte sich im kollektiven Unterbewusstsein dieser Affenpopulation halt. Aber wie hat man das festgestellt? Also heißt das, dass man auch jetzt einen Affen, der da geboren wird, großzieht und er kriegt jetzt das nicht gezeigt und dann stellt man ihm das hin und dann weiß er es auch sofort? Also man kann die Methode sicherlich da ein bisschen anzweifeln, aber es gab halt irgendwann einen Sprung, wo man nicht mehr sagen kann, die Kurve verläuft gleichmäßig, sondern plötzlich erreichte diese Idee, diese erreichte dann halt plötzlich alle.
Ich glaube, man kann da einfach von Selbstständigung reden. Das ist jetzt nicht mehr eine bloße Funktion, die man sehr einfach auf ein paar andere Bedingungen zurückführen kann, sondern das ist etwas, was sich wirklich selbst vervielfältigt, was gerade funktioniert, weil es selbst in sich Eigenfaktor trägt, die dazu beitragen, dass es sich noch weiter verbreitet und dass es sich auch einigermaßen selbst am Leben erhält, vielleicht sogar unabhängig davon, ob es jetzt konkreten Nutzen beispielsweise für die Affen hat, denn in dem Fall für die ersten Paare, natürlich, die lernen das einfach, weil sie dann halt beispielsweise die Dosen besser öffnen können und dass man sie einen konkreten Nutzen hat, aber ab irgendeinem Punkt stört sozusagen nicht mehr die Frage gestellt, muss ich das jetzt wissen, um da einen Nutzen von zu haben, sondern das verselbstständigt sich in einem Maße, Das ist einfach, das ist halt so und da braucht gar nicht mehr groß drüber nachgedacht werden.
Man nimmt das Wissen von jemand anderem an, ohne dass einem der Nutzen in dem Moment klaut. So ähnlich wie halt in der Genetik halt am Anfang ist es sinnvoll, sich gegen spezielle Krankheiten oder sowas zu schützen und dann gibt es seine Partnerselektion darauf. Aber irgendwann ist das einfach da. Da ist das einfach Teil des Genpuls, Allergie gegen eine bestimmte Sache oder Resistenz gegen eine bestimmte Krankheit.
Und wenn das sich einmal auf der Art verfestigt hat, dann kann es sich sozusagen unabhängig von dem Ursprungszweck fortentwickeln und bei vielerlei sowas ganz anderes werden.
Das heißt, das Internet ist dann irgendwann doof, aber es macht einem nichts mehr aus, weil man ist ja dagegen resistent. Nee, die Idee war, also woran ich das halt gemerkt habe, ich habe sehr lange immer wieder Leuten erklärt müssen, was ist Datenfernübertragung, was ist Internet, was ist Vernetzung. Und irgendwann kamen diese Fragen nicht mehr. Ohne dass ich jetzt sagen könnte, dass ich weiß, woher meine buckelige Verwandtschaft das gelernt hat, das war irgendwie Teil... Und sie könnten wahrscheinlich auch selber nicht mehr sagen, woher sie es ist. Richtig, genau. Es ist nicht so der und der hat es mir erklärt, sondern man weiß es einfach. Es war einfach als Idee plötzlich da und hatte sich so wie man Pop-Songs kennt, ohne sagen zu können, woher man sie eigentlich kennt. Richtig. Mir geht das so. Ich nehme jetzt eigentlich an Radio, Bespielungen, Fernsehen, eigentlich gar nicht mehr teil und das schon seit geraumer Zeit. Bin aber dann trotzdem immer wieder überrascht, dass ich irgendwelche Lieder kenne. Zumindest mal so von der Melodie her. Wüsste aber jetzt gar nicht, warum eigentlich. Da fand ich auch das interessant, was Christian noch als Beispiel genannt hat, mit diesen Falschhören. Also diesen Monde Greens ist glaube ich der Fachausdruck dafür, Monde Greens. Das sind halt falsch gehörte Liedtexte, die aber ein Eigenleben entwickelt haben. Und ein Beispiel dafür ist dieser Jimi Hendrix-Song. Ich weiß den Titel nicht, aber da kommt diese Zeile drin vor. Excuse me while I kiss the sky. Im Original oder in dem Fall? Im Original. Also, entschuldige mich, ich muss mal gerade den Himmel küssen. Und das hört sich halt schnell so an wie Kiss this guy, diesen Typenkissen. Und das hatten auch so viele Leute dann so im Ohr, dass es dann sozusagen eine Memerückkopplung gab und dass Jimi Hendrix wirklich auf dem Konzert dann halt auch seinen Bassisten abgeknutscht hat an dieser Stelle. Also das heißt, das Falsche hatte sich memetisch weiter durchgesetzt als das Richtige. Ja, das ist so wie mit Schau mir in die Augen kleines. Das kennt sicherlich auch jeder. Aus Casablanca. Genau. Wenn man sich allerdings Casablanca anschaut, stellt man fest, dass dieser Satz dort nicht fällt. Ist das nicht die deutsche Version von Here's looking at you, kid? Siehst du, genau. Ich sehe in deine Augen kleines, sagt er. Niemand zitiert es so. Auch, dass es nichts mit dem Original zu tun hat, finde ich zumindest. Es ist schon mal eine sehr freie Übersetzung. Aber selbst die freie Übersetzung hat es irgendwie nicht geschafft. Irgendjemand fing halt mal an zu sagen, ich schaue in deine Augen, das ist wahrscheinlich der erste Schritt. Dann ist das aber eine komische Variante. Dann hat irgendjemand wahrscheinlich mal angefangen zu sagen, schau mir in die Augen. Wahrscheinlich ist es auch das, was die bessere Übersetzung gewesen wäre. Hätte man das von vornherein gemacht, dann hätte es auch als solches verfangen. Aber es war wahrscheinlich schlecht übersetzt. Und irgendwie hat sich so in den Köpfen das dann festgezogen.
Und da haben wir dann auch schon ein gutes Beispiel, was an Memen so spannend sein kann, weil sie sich halt anpassen, genauso wie sich halt Leben an sein Umfeld anpasst, passen sich auch Memen an ihr Umfeld an und optimieren sich gewissermaßen hin. In dieses Umfeld hinein und besonders gut da hinein zu passen. Und in so einem Fall ist halt aus irgendwelchen Gründen die Ursprungsformulierung nicht so toll oder zu umständlich oder einfach nicht so gut haftenbleibend, wie das, was sich dann durchgesetzt hat. Und die Leute haben auf diese Weise die Synchronisation gewissermaßen verbessert. Sie haben sie evolutionär optimiert, dadurch, dass sie den Begriff ständig überall in Konfrontation gebracht haben mit Auslesebedingungen, wie meinetwegen, wie umständlich lässt sich das sagen, wie gut kommt das an, wie hört sich das an. Und in dieser Weise, das ist dann halt so eine Verselbständigung, wo dann dem Text dann gar nicht mehr so wichtig ist, ob er jetzt irgendwie dem Übersetzungsgeist des ursprünglichen Drehbuchautors, der Übersetzung entspringt, sondern er sich sagt, also das ist jetzt natürlich sehr metaphorisch gesprochen, er sich sagt, ich möchte lieber einfach für mich besser funktionieren und interessiere mich nicht so sehr dafür, ob ich jetzt meinetwegen der Ideologie des Übersetzers entspreche.
Was ist denn jetzt, also warum in diesem Buch, warum hat er denn überhaupt das mit dem Memen, so ging es im Wesentlichen das Memen, ich meine das Buch heißt das egoistische oder das selfish egoistische, ich weiß nicht, ob das eine gute Übersetzung ist. Aber so heißt der deutsche Titel, okay, wie auch immer.
Aber nein, also es ist eigentlich nur ein Kapitel im Ganzen und das Kapitel hat mehr so den, ich zeige mehr so den Antrieb, ich zeige euch mal, dass das ein allgemeines Prinzip ist, faut mal her, man kann das ja auch auf ganz andere Sachen anwenden. Also das eigentlich ist es.
Das heißt, dieses Kapitel hat sich auch verselbstständigt an der Stelle.
Also wenn man den Begriff des Memes anwenden möchte, dann kann man sagen, der Begriff des Memes selbst ist ein gigantisches Mem.
Ah, okay, das Mem ist ein gigantisches Mem, das ist so ein bisschen wie GNU, das ist so ein bisschen mit totalem Selbstbezug. Und natürlich ist das auch alles viel älter als das Internet. Also Meme gibt es schon in der Bibel, es gibt den Begriff des Shiboleth. Ein Shiboleth ist eine sprachliche Eigenheit, die man beobachtet, um Leute aus einer bestimmten regionalen oder sozialen Gruppe zusammenzubringen. Da gibt es, ich glaube, ich habe es eben gerade noch in Wikipedia nachgeschlagen, im Buch der Richter, so eine Stelle, wo halt ein hebräischer Stamm… Das ist ein altes Testament oder was? Ja, genau, altes Testament. Da wird halt irgendwelchen Feinden gesagt, sag doch einmal das Wort Shibolet, das hebräische Wort für Getreideähre. Und wenn sie Sibolet sagen, also nicht mit dem Sch, dann war klar, das ist die Feindesgruppe. Und das gibt es auch heute noch. Also in Köln ist halt sehr beliebt so ein Test als Shibolet, dass man irgendwie einem Zugereisten sagt, Sarenz Eynz blodworscht und dann brechen sich die ganzen Zugereisten bei dem Wort blodworscht einen ab und man weiß halt, das ist kein Kölner, weil der Kölner sagt, Pflönz. Und ja, also wenn du halt... Jede, so jüdische Volksfront und Volksfront von Judäa. Shibolet ist sozusagen ein Passwort, was dich zu einer Insider-Gruppe macht. Also daran kannst du halt erkennen, der gehört dazu oder der gehört nicht dazu. Und wir kennen das in der Hacker-Kultur genauso. Also da wird dann halt, wenn es um irgendwelche Zufallszahlen geht, nehmen wir mal ein beliebiges Beispiel hier 23 oder 42 und so. Und der ganze Saal lacht, außer denen, die das Shibolet halt nicht verstehen.
Das ist auch, glaube ich, ein gutes Beispiel dafür, dass es halt schon um sehr allgemeine Strukturen geht. Und der Begriff Memen jetzt einfach nur eine sehr spezielle, der spezieller Versuch ist, ein wissenschaftliches Vokabular für etwas zu entwickeln, was eigentlich grundlegende Prozesse von Kultur allgemein befreit. Und man deshalb vielleicht den Begriff auch ein bisschen aufweichen kann und durch andere Begriffe auch ersetzen kann.
Wie lange ist es jetzt eigentlich her, dass dieser Begriff Memen aus diesem Buch entfleucht ist? Und wirklich, also wann hat er sich denn im Internet manifestiert?
Ich glaube schon recht früh, also ich kann da jetzt keine genauen Daten nennen, aber es ist halt einfach eine Metapher, die sich sehr gut anwenden ließ auf bestimmte Phänomene im Netz und die wahrscheinlich einfach dadurch schon Eigenleben dort entwickelt hat. Also es gab auch noch Versuche allgemein, diesen Membegriff, wie ihn Dawkins geschaffen hat, eine eigene Wissenschaft zu übersetzen und das ist auch immer mal wieder, das hat sich auch eine Weile lang hingezogen, aber so richtig ein Erfolgsmodell der Memetik ist daraus noch nicht geworden, während halt der Begriff im Internet recht sorglos einfach angewendet wird für eine Vielzahl von Phänomenen und dort halt als Begriff des Internetmemes sehr viel laxer, aber auch sehr viel populärer und mit sehr viel mehr Durchschlagskraft halt angewendet wird. Und insofern entstammt er zwar so dem Dawkins Buch und entstammt auch ein gewisser Maßen einer wissenschaftlichen Tradition, die sich damit verbindet, aber ist halt im Internet, glaube ich, noch mal als ein eigenständiger Begriff zu betrachten.
Ja, ich meine, wir reden hier auch ganz schlau daher, aber letztendlich gibt es halt auch eine riesige Spaßkomponente bei dem Ganzen. Das ist auch dann nicht so viel anders, als das, was jeder irgendwie so aus seiner Schulzeit kennt. Da gab es dann irgendwelche Insider-Witze von irgendwelchen Gruppen. Und wenn man das dann nicht verstanden hat, dann hieß es dann nur, ja, da hättest du dabei sein müssen. Das war total lustig und so. Und genau das hast du jetzt halt potenziert auf mehrere Millionen Menschen gleichzeitig im Internet. Wenn du dabei warst, dann findest du das auch lustig. Wobei man im Internet halt auch immer nachträglich noch mal dabei sein kann. Ja, was sind denn jetzt so mal gute Beispiele für so frühe Meme des Netzes? Was hat denn jetzt so die die Netzbrennen, Kulturbrennenkammer da so hervorgebracht?
Beispielsweise, ich bin mir jetzt wieder nicht über die Jahreszahlen so genau klar, aber glaube ich ein sehr gutes Beispiel für ein uraltes Internet-Meme war halt das Dancing Baby, was halt, ich weiß nicht, das gibt es schon lange, ja. Genau, was es ja auch vor allem sehr gut gefasst hat, sich auch zu verbreiten, also ein bisschen halt in Fernsehszenen wie Ally McBeal oder beispielsweise auch der Hamster Dance, was halt einfach nur eine Seite mit nervigen tanzenden Hamstern ist.
Und diese schreckliche Musik aus Robin Hood von Disney. Was hat das mit dem Dancing Baby zu tun?
Nee, das sind dann beiden Fällen, sind halt kulturelle Texte, die sich einfach, oder halt was auch von einem etwas älteren Memen ist, was aber immer noch sehr populär ist, ist halt beispielsweise Goatse.
Ja, das solltet ihr mal dann selber googeln.
Ja, ja. Oder auch nicht.
Oder auch nicht.
Wir müssen einen Warnhinweis anbieten. Ihr wollt das nicht wissen. Not safe for work. Wenn ihr es nicht wisst, ihr wollt es nicht wissen.
Aber bei Goatse ist es auch ganz interessant, dass man bei Wikipedia relativ gefahrlos nachlesen kann. Genau. Sagen wir mal so, wenn wir es ganz abstrakt sagen, es ist ein kultureller Text, der auch sehr gerne als Initiationsritus quasi ins Netz missbraucht werden konnte. Das heißt, man hat halt diese Sache verlinkt und Leute haben halt draufgeklickt und da hat man dann sehr gut die Leute feiden können, die das vorher mal gesehen hatten. Denn wenn man einmal dort gewesen war, dann bleibt es auch haften und man ist sozusagen, man kann es nicht mehr wegwaffen und halt den Leuten, die sich davon noch tatsächlich haben folkieren lassen, wenn sie es zum ersten Mal gesehen haben. Und da kann man auch selber vielleicht sehr gut so Gruppendynamiken erforfen, so der gehört dazu und der gehört nicht dazu.
Und das sehen wir sozusagen tough genug ist für das Internet. Grob gesagt geht es bei diesem kulturellen Text, wie du so schön sagst, also es ist ein Bild und das hat was mit erwachsene Unterhaltung und Körpermodifikation zu tun. Aber du hast ja vorhin gesagt, Beispiele von, also Dawkins hat es ja vor allem über die über die Sprache überhaupt erstmal definiert, richtig?
Nein, das Problem bei Dawkins ist halt, dass er einen sehr allgemeinen Begriff nimmt, Memen und halt Beispiele dafür sucht, sowas lässt sich sehr gut nachweisen bei so etwas wie Sprache beispielsweise, weil halt...
Ja gut, aber wenn es sich so gut nachweisen lässt, müsste es sich ja auch bei den Internet-Memen gut nachweisen lassen.
Genau, also nochmal zu der Allgemeinheit des Begriffs, der verwendet den Begriff halt auch so auf so was wie Ideen, Religion und so was ja sehr wabbelige Körper sind, die man sehr schlecht festmachen kann, während halt im Internet, Internet-Meme sind eigentlich immer ziemlich klare, klar fest machbare Texte, also entweder sind es halt tatsächlich einfach nur Buchstabenkombination oder es sind halt konkrete Bilder oder Töne.
Buchstabenkombinationen wie was?
Beispielsweise so popular catchphrases, also beispielsweise gibt es halt immer wiederkehrende Sätze, beispielsweise in Slashdot-Diskussionen, wie beispielsweise das Simpsons-Zitat, I for one, welcome our... irgendwas einsetzen, overlords. Das ist dann so eine Phrase, die in jedem Kontext eigentlich, wo irgendwie eine neue Technologie die Waage vielleicht bedrohlich sein könnte oder so vorgestellt wird, muss immer jemand diesen Spruch bringen und immer ausgefüllt halt mit einer Einsetzung.
Oder irgendwelche Hardware, Imagine a Bio-Gruf, Cluster of this. Genau.
Und das sind halt sehr konkret nachweisbare Texte. Das heißt, ich könnte einfach bei Google halt dieses Textmuster eingeben und könnte mir dann halt genau anzeigen lassen, dass das irgendwie so und so viele tausendmal bei Slashdot vorgekommen ist. Und insofern kann man so den Begriff des Memes, wenn man ihn einfach als ein Informationsmuster, was aus bestimmten Gründen sich sehr gut vervielfältigt, festmacht, kann man ihn wahrscheinlich an digitalen Inhalten sehr gut nachweisen. Also deshalb an Texten, an Bildern, an Videos, an Sound-Ateilen.
Aber was bringt die Leute jetzt dazu, diesen Satz zu wiederholen? Also was steckt da drin? Ich glaube, da kommt dann halt so eine Sache noch ins Spiel, was halt auch relativ neu ist. Also auf jeden Fall nicht 10, 15 Jahre, sondern ein bisschen neuer. Nämlich, dass das Web jetzt halt auch zum Mitmachen geeignet ist und dass Leute halt irgendwie eigene Kreationen ins Web reinstellen. Und zwar einfach und so. Auch so was wie Photoshop-Skills sind jetzt halt sozusagen als Memen schon komplett durchgesickert. Das heißt, das machen nicht mehr die Spezialexperten, sondern das kann irgendwie jeder machen. Irgendjemand fängt halt mal an und stellt irgendetwas ins Netz. Und andere Leute arbeiten sich dann an diesem Ding ab. Es gibt halt auch eine richtige Kultur von Umgebung, wo sowas dann halt wirklich dann so quasi als Sport betrieben wird. Wer treibt es dann noch mehr auf die Spitze? Zum Beispiel... Man lässt sich inspirieren. Genau, man lässt sich inspirieren und irgendwann wird es zum Selbstläufer. Dann hat das Memen halt überlebt. Also das, was Christian erwähnte, diese Satzfetzen oder sowas, das sind halt sogenannte Snowclones, sozusagen Schablonen, wo man dann Sachen einsetzen kann. Also im Moment gerade sehr beliebt ist dieses Xebit-Meme. Also da gibt es einen sehr hübschen Lehrfilm darüber, wie man dieses Memen korrekt anwendet. Wie macht man das? Genau, also man hat einen Satz und der sagt, der fängt immer mit Yodog oder Subdog, I heard you like Aktivität, so I put a Nomen 1 in your Nomen 2, so you can verb von Aktivität, while you can verb. Das heißt …Okay, jetzt musst du mal was einsetzen. Jetzt muss ich mal was einsetzen. Also das Ganze kommt aus dieser unsäglichen MTV-Show Pimp My Ride. Das ist irgendwie Motorrad-Umbauen, oder Auto-Tunen oder so. Genau, und es ist halt komplett absurd. Da ist so ein Rapper, der besucht Leute, und dann erzählen die halt so, ja, ich koch auch so gerne, und außerdem ist mein Wagen ganz schlecht. Und dann bringt der die halt zu einem sehr absurden Tuning-Shop, und die sagen dann, ja, erst mal hier, ne, tiefer legen, und Spoiler und so weiter. Und weil der so gerne kocht, bauen wir da auch noch eine Einbauküche rein. Und dann wird das dann am Schluss präsentiert, und die Leute flippen total aus, und dieser Rapper sagt dann halt hier, ich hab gehört, du kochst gerne, also hab ich dir meine Einbauküche in dein Auto gebaut, dann kannst du kochen, während du fährst. Und das war jetzt schon diese Satzkonstruktion? Das war diese Satzkonstruktion, und das kann man natürlich dann immer absurder machen. Also angefangen hat's einfach mit einem Bild von diesem Moderator und darunter stand Your dog, I heard you like driving, so I put a car in your car, so you can drive while you drive. Und das ist halt auch rekursiv, das heißt also die Nerds werden da angesprochen, also die kennen halt alle irgendwie das mit Rekursiv und Funktion und Lambda-Kalkül und Funktion in Funktion und so weiter. Das heißt, ein Nerd, der was auf sich hält, der fängt dann sofort an und denkt sich, wie kann ich das dann jetzt noch auf die Spitze treiben?
Das ist auch, glaube ich, das Spannende, dass es halt so ein richtiges, mafinelles Durcharbeiten von Memen gibt, was auch beispielsweise was ganz anderes ist, als wenn ich jetzt irgendwie in einer klassischen Künstlerideologie bin und jetzt irgendwie besonders originelle, komplexe Kunstwerke faffen möchte, während es halt bei Memen einfach Spaß macht auf teilweise sehr, sehr, sagen wir mal, maschinenstupide Weise Sachen durchzuarbeiten, einfach zu gucken, was dann daraus entsteht. Und dann so am Ende hat man dann irgendwie 5.000 Mal was durchdekliniert und der Großteil davon ist eigentlich irgendwie nicht so spannend, aber daraus entstehen dann halt dann irgendwie unerwartet Kombinationen, die plötzlich sich dann wiederum sehr gut erneut durchsetzen und dann hat man so ein Mem, was dann ein neues Mem gebiert und das wird sich dann weiter fort und so weiter.
Und auch das kann man nochmal auf die Spitze treiben. Also das Mem, das ein neues Mem gebiert, kann man halt auch nochmal in ein weiteres Mem packen, sodass man memen kann, während man memt, sozusagen. Es gibt das Comic XKCD. Mit diesem Strichmännchen kennt glaube ich jeder. Kennt jeder. In Nordkreisen extrem populär, würde ich sagen. Da gibt es, user-friendly und alle anderen mittlerweile Popularität deutlich überholt, wie sie den einlaufen. Da gab es vor kurzem so ein Bild, so eine Bedszene, ein Typ und seine Freundin und er sagte dann halt irgendwie Yo, I heard you don't like forming baby. But I accidentally in your base.
Jetzt brauchst du jetzt glaube ich einen ganz langen Appendix, der das alle sagt.
Allerdings, das war jetzt und darunter stand einfach nur Ich bin so stolz, dass ich das lustig finden kann. Darunter stand einfach nur Gegenargument, gegen diese Situation, irgendwie Leben ruiniert, aber pro irgendwie die höchste Memedichte, die einfach möglich ist, in einem Satz. Das müssen wir jetzt mal auseinandernehmen, wenn du sie noch alle zusammenkriegst. Ja, Yo, I heard you don't like forming baby. Also es gibt einen... Das bezieht sich auf was? How is baby formed?
Das können wir auch gut einspielen.
Wie schreibt man denn das? Baby mit BB. So ähnlich wie Baby, wie es richtig wäre. Und zwar gibt es einen... Ja, wie soll ich das sagen? Ein Ort, wo sich sagen wir mal das Netzpräkariat trifft. Das ist Yahoo Ansatz oder Yahoo Questions. Wie heißt das? Wo man Fragen stellen kann. Und andere Leute, die genauso wenig Ahnung haben, wie man selber, antworten dann darauf. Also es ist keine Expertenrunde. Doch, ja, ich glaube so was war gedacht gewesen. Aber ist nicht so? Ich treib mich da wenig rum. Ach, das ist das Netzpräkariat. Ja, also das sind sozusagen die Fernfahrer auf der Datenautobahn, würde ich mal so sagen. Oder die Mantafahrer auf der Datenautobahn. Und da kommt diese Frage her. Da gab es irgendwie einen Austausch, wo halt zwei Leute mit völlig verstümmelten, also ich glaube, es sollte Englisch sein, aber war nur noch in Resten erkennbar. Also die Frage war, how is baby formed? How does girl get pregnant? Und in dem gleichen Stil wurde dann halt auch darauf geantwortet und man schlug sie einfach nur die Hand vor das Gesicht und dachte irgendwie, das darf alles nicht wahr sein. Dieser Text wurde dann herauskopiert, wurde in eine Flash-Animation gepackt, mit zwei Neandertaler, die sich da unterhalten in diesem Stil. Okay, das war das eine Meme.
Und als Tonspur auch sehr schön. Richtig. Auch dieses, wir müssten mal YouTube-Kommentare vorlesen, Autoren ist quasi da praktiziert mit wir lesen das einfach wortwörtlich so vor, wie es da steht.
Das ist absurd. Es ist wirklich absurd. Also da kommt dieser erste Satz jetzt her. Na, der erste Teil war ja Your Dog, I heard you don't like forming baby. Also das ist halt dieses XCB Dingster, I heard you. Und da könnte man jetzt auch noch ein bisschen Fantasie sagen, also dieses I heard, you like, gibt's auch noch mal in anderen Memen, das ist eine sogenannte Copypaster, das ist eine Geschichte, die anfängt, wo halt ein Satz sehr zentral ist, der heißt I heard you like Mudkips. Das sind für diejenigen, die jetzt über 20 sind, eine bestimmte Pokémon-Sorte. Und da wird halt einfach eine Geschichte erzählt und dass jemand in der Schule jemand anders fragt, irgendwie ich hab gehört, du magst gerne Mudkips und dann macht der da irgendwie mit einer Mudkip-Stofffigur rum und so weiter. Und diese Geschichte wird dann einfach kopiert und wieder neu reingepostet in irgendwelche Boards, Diskussionsrunden oder so, weil sie halt einfach so schön peinlich und lustig ist. Wer das jetzt endlich das erste Mal erzählt hat diese Geschichte, keine Ahnung. Also ist auch nicht mehr so richtig wichtig. Also Autor in dem Sinne gibt's da gar nicht. Das ist halt so postmoderne Literatur- Theoretiker wie Foucault hätten da irgendwie ihre helle Freude, weil es gibt keine Autor-Funktion mehr, sondern nur noch den reinen Diskurs. Ja, und das könnte halt auch in diesem XKCD-Ding drin sein und dann But I Accidentally In Your Base. Also das mit Accidentally steht schon mal wieder für sich, ne? Das kenne ich, das ist dieser gloriose, also wenn ich richtig informiert bin, korrigiert mich. Meiner Auffassung nach war das mal so ein Chat-Protokoll. Richtig. Und wo irgendjemand jemand anderes aufgezogen hat. Also ich vermute, das war sozusagen die also einer hat halt angefangen und und das mir überlegen, die Aussage war War es nicht mit der Coca-Cola-Flasche? Accidentally the whole Genau, I Accidentally the whole Coca-Cola-Botte. Und dem anderen fehlte das Verb. Und fragt dann wie blöd er nach, irgendwie Ja, you Accidentally what? The whole Coca-Cola-Botte. Und die anderen werden wahnsinnig, weil man immer irgendwie was weggelassen hat. Das ist übrigens auch ein sehr schönes Ding, andere so ein bisschen an seiner eigenen Sprache wahnsinnig werden zu lassen. Das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es auch nochmal so einen spezifischen Reiz hat. Ich hatte damals so in meiner Peer-Group in meinem jugendlichen Leichtsinn hatten wir dann so eine kleineren Gruppe von Leuten, die wir alle so ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen, einerseits dem Sprachwitz frönten, andererseits auch irgendwie andere Leute zu verwirren, ganz toll fanden, haben uns dann irgendwie eine eigene Sprache zugelegt. Die Sprache nannten wir Sprache. Und diese Sprache zu sprechen, hieß Sprache sprechen. Und der eigentliche Witz war da drin, dass man eigentlich den deutschen Satzbau ganz einfach umgebaut hat. Und was weggelassen hat. Das heißt, anstatt ich gehe nach Hause, hat man gesagt, nach Hause gehe. Das heißt, das Subjekt fiel weg und Verb und Objekt wurden einfach getauscht. Klingt jetzt erstmal ganz einfach, wenn man das aber dann konsequent umsetzt und anfängt, Sprache zu sprechen. Irgendwann nur noch Sprache sprichst und Leute das komisch finden, für dich aber ganz vollkommen normal ist. Und andere total verwirrt werden. Und wir Sprache immer weitergesprochen haben. So ist es halt einfach. Wenn das einer macht, ist es irgendwie komisch. Aber wenn dann viele das machen, dann fühlt derjenige, der es nicht macht, der fühlt sich dann richtig komisch. Weil er so in dieser Situation ist, oh mein Gott, irgendwie, the world is turning around me, bin ich jetzt verrückt oder sind alle anderen verrückt?
Da greift doch, glaube ich, wieder so ein bisschen diese Biologische Metapher. Es ist so ein Virus, das Leute ansteckt und irgendwann ist man so der Letzte. Man muss quasi von den Zombies auch gebissen werden, damit man überhaupt nicht mehr sich ausgegrenzt fühlt.
Und natürlich greift auch dieses, im Grunde ist es albern. Im Grunde ist es echter Kinderkram, den jeder so macht. Früher war das, wie du sagst, in der Peer-Group. Jetzt haben wir das Internet, jetzt ist es in der Peer-to-Peer-Group, also echt noch mal millionenfach verstärkt. Und jetzt hast du halt solche Phänomene, die hätten sich früher auf eine Schulklasse oder so was beschränkt, was vielleicht auch in manchen Fällen ganz gut ist, weil da ist halt auch viel dummes Zeug dabei. Und das hast du jetzt halt komplett weltweit im Internet. Jetzt müssen wir noch mal den letzten Bestandteil dieses XKCD-Comics noch mal auflösen. Also Sub-Dog, ich hab das hier gerade mal aufgeschlagen. Sub-Dog mit D-A-W-G. Gehört das immer noch alles zu dem gleichen? Das war noch alles mit dem Forming Babby sozusagen. Lenny, das ist dieses Sub-Dog, I heard you like driving, so I put a car in your car. Ach so, okay, alles klar. Dann das mit dem Forming Babby, dann eine Accidentally in your base. Was ich ganz offensichtlich auf... Audio base, I belong to us, bitte. Richtig, das ist ein japanisches Videospiel, Zeroing, und das fängt halt, wie das so schön ist, mit so einem Intro an, und dieses Intro war halt auf japanisch, aber es ist dann halt auch im Westen rausgekommen und in einer Form, ja, also die Übersetzung ist verbesserungswürdig. Kann man so sagen, ja. Man fühlt sich da noch irgendwie sehr, sehr außerirdisch, also das fängt an mit so und so War was beginning, Captain, we get signal, Mainscreen turn on, also es ist halt schon sowas Ähnliches wie Englisch, deswegen kann sich es halt auch international ausbreiten, wenn es halt kaputtes Japanisch wäre, dann wäre das wahrscheinlich nicht so populär, oder selbst wenn es kaputtes Deutsche ist, dann wäre es halt auf die deutsche Sprechergruppe, aber kaputtes Englisch versteht halt echt jeder. Aber so richtig lustig geworden ist es eigentlich erst dadurch, dass es genommen wurde und da bin ich mir nicht ganz so sicher, dann gab es irgendwann mal dieses großartige Video dazu, ob das schon kam, als es schon bekannt war, oder ob das dazu beigetragen hat, das so bekannt zu machen, ist mir nicht bekannt. Das ist halt der Punkt, das ist genau wie mit dem 100. Affen, man weiß einfach echt nicht mehr, es ist einfach irgendwann da, und du weißt nicht mehr genau, wer den Stein jetzt ins Rollen gebracht hat, sondern ab einem bestimmten Punkt überschwemmt es uns einfach und wird halt Teil unseres kollektiven Unterbewusstseins.
So ein Meme ist es ab dem Moment, wo die Genealogie nicht mehr möglich ist, wo die zusammenbricht, das hinterherreffieren, wo kommt das eigentlich her und warum hat sich das in dem und dem Rahmen irgendwie breit gemacht, und ab dem Moment, wo es einfach vor allem bei einem Eigenleben entwickelt, was man nicht mehr zurückführen kann auf, ja, der hat das dort verwendet und deshalb ist der jetzt der Autor des Auftaurens dort. Ab dem Moment ist es dann halt ein Internet-Meme.
Bei Blinkenlight hat uns das natürlich auch verfolgt. Also beim ersten Blinkenlight 2001 gab es natürlich auch irgendwann den unvermeidlichen audio-base-are-belong-to-us-scroll-Text. Und jetzt beim letzten bei Stereo-Scope haben wir uns ja dann auch nochmal einen Rick Astley gegönnt. Naja, ich meine, ich würde auch sagen, dass das ganze Projekt ist halt auch auf einem Meme basierend. Also dieses Pseudo-Deutsch, was da auf so einem Warnschild relaxen und watchende Blinkenlights. Das stimmt. Das ist halt sozusagen echt ein Protomem. Das wurde halt in den 80ern noch so ganz hardcore auf Xerox-Kopierer kopiert und dann von Rechenzentrum zu Rechenzentrum weitergeleitet, weil die hatten ja nichts. Die hatten ja keine Image-Boards damals. Und das wurde auch immer, das stimmt, jetzt wo du es sagst, und es wurde ja auch dann immer noch modifiziert, weil das Original war ja schlecht. Was ist denn das Original? Das Original, das weiß man, das Original ist, also was heißt, das weiß man, also was so angenommen wird, ist, dass es mal einen Originaltext gab. Das muss ich jetzt gleich nochmal nachschlagen. Und der war halt nicht so witzig. Tja, jetzt muss ich gleich mal nachschauen, wo guckt man denn das eigentlich nach? Wahrscheinlich in der Wikipedia. Gott sei Dank gibt es die Wikipedia. Genau, also Wikipedia hält es halt auch so fest. Das ist ja derzeit irgendwie die einzige Möglichkeit, die Ursprung der Meme noch nachzuziehen. Nein, das würde ich an dieser Stelle mal ganz stark verneinen, weil das ist für mich einer der großen Schwachpunkte der Wikipedia. Oh, das würde ich hier auch gerade verneinen.
Ich stelle hier gerade fest, das ist alles nicht relevant genug für die Wikipedia.
Ganz genau. Also ich weiß nicht, was das ist. Wikipedia könnte diese Rolle hervorragend spielen, aber sie wollen es nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Selbsthass ist oder sowas, aber alles, was mit Netzkultur und Nebenquatsch zu tun hat, das ist grundsätzlich nicht relevant. Und das ist bei der deutschsprachigen... Ist das von der Deutschen oder von der Englischen? Bei beiden. Aber bei der Deutschen ist es halt einfach hardcore. Also wenn es im Verdacht steht, irgendwas mit Netzkultur zu tun zu haben, dann wird es schon mal aus Prinzip schnell gelöscht. Und bei der Englischen ist es aber auch genauso. Also da muss sehr, sehr viel Überzeugungsarbeit geleistet werden, bis so was, was aus dem Netz selber rausgekommen ist und was Kultur ist in meinen Augen und was auch nirgendswo sonst dokumentiert wird, wenn nicht in der Wikipedia. Ja, das fällt da einfach raus. Weil richtige Kultur ist halt Goethe und Shakespeare und so.
Naja, also das ist halt für die Wikipedia, gilt es halt erst dann als angekommen, wenn es halt gespiegelt wurde über eine netzexterne Öffentlichkeit. Und da sind jetzt zwei Faktoren wichtig. Einerseits, dass das Netz unglaublich schnelllebig ist. Und zweitens, dass Netzkultur vor allem im Netz stattfindet. Und das trägt halt dazu bei, dass man nicht unbedingt sehr viel davon in der Wikipedia gespiegelt findet. Weil eigentlich müsste es erstmal in wissenschaftlichen Untersuchungen über mehrere Jahre erst irgendwie niedergefrieben worden sein auf totem Holz, damit es in der Wikipedia als Teil von Netzkultur akzeptiert wird.
Also ein Beispiel, was jeder kennt, sind diese Katzenbilder im Internet, die Lollcats. Und die sind halt für die Wikipedia erst dann relevant geworden, als der in der New York Times oder so ein Artikel darüber entstanden ist. Aber da kannte das schon jeder, da war das Thema schon durch. Lollcats.
Und deshalb, das ist die paradoxe Situation, dass so eine nicht sehr wissenschaftliches Wiki wie die Encyclopedia Dramatica viel informativer und brauchbarer ist als die Wikipedia in solchen Dingen.
Was Meme betrifft.
Richtig.
Es ist halt ein Fach-Wiki für Meme, beziehungsweise ein Fach-Wiki für Trollereien. Also da findet man halt das Internet in seiner ganzen Schönheit und Abscheulichkeit. Artikel, die halt voll sind mit übelstem Rassismus, Menschenverachtung und niedlichen Katzenbildern. Jetzt noch mal zum Thema. Ich hab das hier gerade noch mal hinterher gedingst mit den Blinkenlichten. Ich staune gerade, weil die Geschichte, noch mal kurz in dem Schild. Es gab halt eine Version in Englisch, also aus der amerikanischen Kultur, von amerikanischen Rechenzentren. Und ich schlage jetzt gerade in einem anderen interessanten Archiv nach, nämlich in dem Jargon-Fall. Aus dem habe ich nämlich die ursprüngliche Geschichte. Und da stand halt das Computer-Maschine, also Maschinen geschrieben. Ist nicht für Gefingerpuken und Mittengrabben, ist easy schnappen der Springenwerk, Lohnfusen und Poppenkorken mit Spitz und Spar. Ist nicht für Gewerken bei das Dumpfkopfen, dass Robbernecken, Sichtsehren, Kippen, das cottonpickenden Hans in das Pocket muss. Relaxen und watchen das Blinkenlicht. Und ich würde es wahrscheinlich auch sagen, es fängt irgendwie cool an, aber im zweiten Teil stirbt es irgendwie für uns. Deswegen gab es dann irgendwann mal die deutsche Version, die also deutsche Geeks, Nerds, Rechenzentrum, Betreiber, was auch immer gemacht haben, die das so ein bisschen umgedreht haben. Und das ist dann sozusagen das Original, was man so eigentlich im Kopf hat. This room is full filled with special elektronische Equipment. Finger grabbing und pressing the knöpkes from the computers is allowed for the experts only. So all the left-handers stay away and do not disturb the brainstorming from here working intelligences. Otherwise you will be out thrown and kicked under the wear. Also please keep still and only watch and astonish the blinking lights. So, für uns in der Höhe irgendwie lustiger, flüssiger, für Englischsprache sicherlich anders. Und dann hat es sozusagen diese Übersetzung in Anführungsstrichen von Blinkenlichten in Blinkenlights, das hat es dann wiederum geschafft, zurück die Definition zu sein für diesen Begriff, ich meine, blinkende Frontpanels von Computern, was wir dann auch sozusagen deswegen auch als Anlass genommen haben, das Projekt zu nennen, gerade weil es eben auch so die Antwort der Deutschen war. Also, Blinkenlights hat eine Menge mit Memetik zu tun, mit Memen zu tun. Das stimmt.
Aber da sieht man dann auch sehr schön, damit Meme, damit Macht von einem Meme entstehen können, ist es immer notwendig, dass es so Modifikationsgelegenheiten und Anlässe gibt. Also, das sieht man, kann man dann sehr gut an Sprache mitverfolgen. Und deshalb, das erklärt vielleicht auch, warum so etwas wie gerade Sprachfehler so machtvolle Meme bilden, weil dann halt irgendwie ein bestimmter Fehler aus irgendwelchen psychologischen, neurologischen Anlässen auch immer sehr attraktiv rüberkommt. Und dass die Gelegenheit, dass man Texte modifizieren kann, das hat man halt sehr primär im Netz. Also normalerweise hat man irgendwie einen Text und den jetzt einerseits eins zu eins zu vervielfältigen oder andererseits eine kleine Modifikation einzubauen, ist quasi vor dem digitalen Zeitalter sehr schwierig. Und jetzt mit dem digitalen Zeitalter ist ja das eins zu eins Kopieren von Texten eigentlich der Normalzustand und gleichzeitig sind die Texte beliebig manipulierbar und gerade dadurch, dass jetzt so etwas wie Photofort beispielsweise für jedermann irgendwie so eine Kulturkompetenz ist, ist dann beispielsweise das Modifizieren von Bildern und so weiter die Quelle für das Entstehen von machtvollen Memen.
Und da gab es halt auch ganz schnell so Foren, wo sich was, was ich designe oder so etwas ausgetauscht habe und gesagt haben, hier guck mal, ich habe mal hier was in Photoshop gebastelt und Dinge, die halt geschoppt sind, auch das ist wiederum ein Meme, ich sehe es an den Pixeln und weil ich schon viele Shops in meiner Zeit gesehen habe, Dinge, die halt gefotoshoppt sind, ja, das war halt am Anfang so, dass man das auf irgendwelchen, wie sagt man das, so Boards, früher hätten wir dazu Mailboxen gesagt, aber halt so Diskussions-, Web-Diskussionsforen oder sowas, da haben halt irgendwie Leute, die mit Photoshop umgehen könnten, haben sich halt ausgetauscht und haben Die haben ihre Kreationen dann vorgestellt. Und irgendwann fing das dann halt so an, dass es halt, ja klar, also es ist nicht mehr attraktiv, eine eins zu eins Kopie von etwas herzustellen, sondern es ist attraktiv, eine Sache zu kopieren und irgendwie noch einen draufzusetzen. Und dann fing's dann halt so richtig an, so Battle-mäßig, wer treibt es dann noch weiter? Wer kann dieses Photoshop-Ding dann noch absurder gestalten? Eins von diesen Image-Boards hat ein japanischer Student in seinem, wie sagt man das, in seinem Studenten-Botheim in Amerika gegründet und dieses Image-Board nannte man, hatte er genannt, Two-Channel, oder Ni-Channel, also japanisch für zwei Kanal, Two-Channel. Und das war halt einfach nur ein Forum, wo Leute Bilder posten konnten und andere Leute haben das kommentiert, finde ich gut, und konnten dann als Reply auch noch weitere Bilder posten. Aber mit jedem Post hängt immer nur ein Bild dran, oder? Ich finde das richtig sehr... Nee, also du kannst entweder mit Text antworten oder mit einem Bild und Text oder nur mit einem Bild. Also es gibt halt diese Diskussions... Aber nicht mit mehreren Bildern pro Post. Doch. Ja, genau. Ein Bild pro Post und dazu dann halt optional noch Text oder umgekehrt. Und das war halt attraktiv. Und das ist halt auch ein bisschen anders als das Usenet, was halt hauptsächlich textbasiert funktioniert hat, lange Zeit. Plötzlich konntest du halt das, was du kreiert hast digital, konntest du dann in Diskussionsforen zur Verfügung stellen und andere Leute konnten das kommentieren, konnten das nehmen, konnten da Mesh-ups von machen und so weiter. Und dieses Ding ist diesem japanischen Studenten dann auch ziemlich schnell so richtig über den Kopf gewachsen. Dieses Diskussionsforum ist wahrscheinlich jetzt das weltweit größte dieser Art, also wahrscheinlich das weltweit größte Diskussionsforum im Internet überhaupt. Das gibt's noch. Das gibt's noch und das ist in Japan halt auch wirklich, ja, immer wieder dann so ein Punkt, dass das halt als Nachrichtenquelle auch benutzt wird, weil Leute da einfach dann als erstes Sachen posten, wenn irgendwas passiert. So Citizen-Journalismus oder wie WikiLeaks oder sowas. Das erfüllt sozusagen Twitter und WikiLeaks in einem. Und dieses Imageboard hatte dann auch am Anfang gleich eine Entscheidung getroffen, die halt auch maßgeblich ist für andere ähnliche Diskussionsfonds, nämlich, dass alle Leute dort posten können, ohne sich anzumelden. Man postet immer anonym. Immer grundsätzlich. Man kann gar nicht anders. Das ist unterschiedlich. Also manchmal kann man halt auch mit Namen posten, aber es wird halt nicht gerne gesehen. Also eigentlich unterhält sich da der anonyme Benutzer mit der anonymen Masse und die anonyme Masse antwortet. Und ja, das ist halt auch irgendwie das Schöne. Es gibt dann halt wirklich auch gar keinen Autor mehr, sondern es gibt dann nur noch das Netzbewusstsein, was irgendwelche Bilder reinschmeißt und das Netzbewusstsein antwortet auf diese Bilder.
Es ist so, das muss man sich mal kulturgefechtlich durch den Kopf gehen lassen. Wir haben halt so seit der Renaissance quasi die Idee, dass irgendwie tolle Kultur eigentlich produziert wird von tollen Individuen, von Genies, die sich irgendwie durch Originalität und besser sein als irgendwie die dumme Masse so ein bisschen hervortun und dafür dann ja auch entsprechend gefeiert werden. Genau, davor war es halt irgendwie Kunst und so, das war so ein anonymes Business, was man in Demut vor, meinetwegen, Religion und dergleichen ausgeführt hat. Oder im Moment ist es irgendwie, man hat so den Autor, der so genialisch gefeiert wird und jetzt entsteht plötzlich so Kultur wiederum aus einer totalen Umkehrung dieser Anordnung. Das heißt, Leute werden angemotzt dafür, wenn sie ihren Namen hinfreiben und das ist mehr so, das ist so ein Korpus, an dem irgendwie eine anonyme, wabernde Masse arbeitet, die sich nicht mehr definieren lässt als irgendwie so ein menschliches Einzelbewusstsein. Und Sachen entstehen nicht daraus, dass sich jemand jetzt irgendwie drei Jahre in seine Kammer zurückzieht und dann darüber nachdenkt, was für ein tolles Endkunstwerk könnte ich jetzt faffen, sondern einfach, es wird einfach erwartet, dass jeder seinen Zahnrädchen-Part erfüllt, in dem er völlig unreflektiert einfach Zeugs in die Soße reinwirft und dann irgendwie einfach nur aus diesem Chaos dann irgendwie etwas spannendes Tolles immergiert.
Deshalb ist es für mich auch völlig unverständlich, dass Wikipedia solche Sachen nicht aufgreift, weil Wikipedia nämlich auf genau diesem Prinzip arbeitet. Also da gibt es auch nicht den Autor des Wikipedia-Artikels, sondern gibt es halt nur die Netzintelligenz, die diesen Artikel gemeinsam geschrieben hat. Und das ist natürlich alles ein bisschen weniger pubertär als bei diesen Imageboards, aber trotzdem das Prinzip ist das Gleiche. Und das ist halt auch etwas, wo wir uns ideengeschichtlich erst echt dran gewöhnen mussten. Also das haben Philosophen schon in den 60er Jahren gesagt, das werden wir irgendwie haben, diese Postmoderne, wo es keinen Autor mehr gibt, sondern noch Ideen, die im Raum rumfliegen und keinen Ursprungspunkt mehr haben. Und jetzt haben wir es halt da. Jetzt benutzen wir halt Betriebssysteme, die nicht von einem Autor stammen wie Linux, sondern von einer Community. Wir lesen unser Wissen nach in der Wikipedia, die nicht von einem Autor stammt und wir machen Witze, wo wir überhaupt nicht mehr wissen, wo die irgendwie mal her kamen. Was ist dein Kritikpunkt an der Wikipedia? Also die Wikipedia könnte sehr sehr schnell solche Netzkultur-Phänomene aufnehmen und es wird halt nirgendswo sonst seriös dokumentiert. Es gibt halt dieses Spaß- und Insiderscherz-Wiki-Encyclopedia Dramatiker, wo halt dann, wo man sich halt auch reinlesen kann, aber wo halt auch eine Menge Mist drin steht und halt auch bewussten Mist drin steht. Und die Wikipedia sagt halt irgendwie, wir kommen aus der Netzkultur, aber wir finden die Netzkultur irgendwie nicht relevant. Und das finde ich absurd.
Ich muss da kurz zur Verteidigung der Wikipedia sagen, die Wikipedia bemüht sich halt tatsächlich irgendeine Art von Seriosität zu entwickeln, mit der man solche Sachen analysieren könnte und mit der man beispielsweise entscheiden könnte, dass jetzt tatsächlich ein Meme und das ist jetzt nicht nur etwas, wo irgendwie einer mal das in Board geschrieben hat und jetzt behauptet, das wäre ein Meme. Und es ist halt wahrscheinlich auch sehr schwierig tatsächlich, irgendeine irgendwie Maßstäbe zu entwickeln, um so etwas zu erfassen. Also denn die Maßstäbe, nach denen wir beispielsweise jetzt einfach per Google irgendwie was eingeben können und gucken, wie viele Seiten wird das jetzt so zitiert, die wandeln sich halt auch sehr schnell und wahrscheinlich ist einfach die Wikipedia inzwischen zu groß und zu einfach aufgrund ihrer Größe zu behebig, um da einfach noch irgendwie schnell in großer Flexibilität Maßstäbe zu entwickeln, während halt so etwas wie Encyclopedia Dramatica tatsächlich da sehr viel besser mitkommt, aber man kann da wirklich kein Seriositätsmaßstab und so etwas wie Encyclopedia Dramatica anlegen. Ich weiß halt sofort, es hat eine ganz andere Herangehensweise an Wissen, sowohl bei so etwas wie Encyclopedia Dramatica oder auch beispielsweise Urban Dictionary weiß ich, Einträge, die ich dort finde, die sind halt nicht mit Sicherheit irgendwie verifiziert. Und da könnte halt auch totaler Unsinn drinne stehen und ich kann das nur als einen Informationsinput unter vielen nehmen. Und so etwas wie Wikipedia verfolgt halt immer noch so das Konzept, wir sind irgendwie schon eine Anlaufstelle, die irgendwie ein gewisses Maß an Autorität für ihre Inhalte behaupten möchte. Und das lässt sich sehr schwer, glaube ich, kombinieren mit dem schnellen Verfolgen, dieser sehr schnelllebigen Phänomene.
Naja, aber die Enzyklopädiadramatiker übernimmt ja an der Stelle wahrscheinlich auch die Funktion, die die Wikipedia am Anfang selbst noch hatte. Ja, aber sie übernimmt halt genauso auch die Funktion, irgendwelche Leute zu beschimpfen und irgendwelchen Quatsch zu verbreiten und so weiter. Und das ist halt auch Teil des Konzepts. Also es ist nicht die wissenschaftliche Meme. Die Wikipedia agiert ja nicht wie eine Person. Ich meine, das ist ja nun auch eine Masse, die sich versucht, dort in eine Richtung zu bewegen. Und ich denke, dass eigentlich wohl alle auch versuchen, sozusagen im Sinne der Wikipedia beizutragen, nur dass nicht unbedingt Gleichheit darüber besteht, was im Sinne der Wikipedia ist. Aber die Diskussion müssen wir jetzt an der Stelle auch richtig. Es geht ja nicht wirklich um Wikipedia. Wir waren eigentlich noch bei den Image-Sports. Ja, und halt auch Encyclopedia Dramatica. Also kurz gesagt, eine Encyclopedia Dramatica lässt sich eigentlich alles finden, was wir jetzt als Internet-Meme hier ansprechen. Sollte ich da hinlegen als Wikipedia diesmal?
Encyclopedia Dramatica ist schon sehr an Fortran vor allem dran und an der damit verbundenen Welt. Und das ist, deshalb wollte ich eigentlich noch mal kurz eingehen. Das ist halt auch, die Encyclopedia Dramatica ist halt auch selber Teil dieser Mememafinerie, die so der Komplex wie beispielsweise Image-Sports darstellen. Das heißt, man postet immer irgendwie ständig Bilder da rein, diese Image-Sports, und manche Bilder setzen sich halt halt sehr populär durch. Und dann tut man die halt also gewissermaßen ins Archiv, Encyclopedia Dramatica. Und dieses Archiv dient dann halt auch als Quelle, um wieder halt Bilder zurück zu posten in die Image-Sports. Und das ist auch ein bisschen sowas, teilweise an Kritik aus so etwas wie Image-Sports kommt. Weil Image-Sports leben sehr von dieser Schnelllebigkeit, weil beispielsweise die Bilder-Threads, die dort aufgemacht werden, werden bei sowas wie Fortran dann einfach regelmäßig immer wieder gelöscht. Und es gibt irgendwie nicht so, dass ich jetzt irgendwie nachfragen kann, was gab es denn jetzt vor drei Jahren hier so an Threads und so. Sondern es ist mehr so, wir filtern einfach durch diese Schnelllebigkeit die guten Meme von den schlechten Memen raus. Und deshalb, damit ein Meme sich durchsetzen kann, müssen sich halt immer wieder neue Leute finden, die es posten. Und so etwas wie Encyclopäder, Dramatiker, sorgt jetzt dafür, dass ich halt tatsächlich nachschlagen kann, was waren denn jetzt so die populären Bilder der letzten paar Jahre. Und das sorgt dann auch dafür, dass halt eine größere Stabilität für manche Inhalte entsteht, weil die halt immer wieder durch diesen, durch dieses Backup Encyclopäder, Dramatiker reproduziert werden können. Und insofern ist die Encyclopäder, Dramatiker auch selbst full daran, dass einige Sachen halt eine größere memetrische Stabilität haben, in diesen Image-Boards.
Fortune hat mir jetzt noch gar nicht definiert. Also wir hatten von diesem japanischen Nijanaro gesprochen und wie gesagt größtes Diskussionsforum der Welt wahrscheinlich. Mittlerweile halt ganz selbstverständlich auch in den japanischen Mainstream-Medien in einer Meldung, im Diskussionskoron. So ist es der Welt, obwohl es eigentlich nur auf japanisch ist oder ist es in vielen Sprachen verfügbar? Das ist nur auf japanisch. Nur auf japanisch. Und ja, also auch diese Wikileaks-Funktion wird er erfüllt. Also Anonymous postet dann halt zum Beispiel irgendwas, Augenzeugenbericht und so weiter. Ja, und dann so Mitte der 90er Jahre ergab es dann halt auch jugendkulturell etwas, dass die Leute halt sehr auf diese japanischen Comics und Zeichentrickserien abgefahren sind. Und einige Geeks haben dann angefangen, japanisch zu lernen, wollten wirklich an die Quelle gehen und sind dann natürlich zwangsläufig irgendwann über Nitschaneroo gestolpert und standen dann einfach fassungslos vor dieser Netzkultur, die es im Westen vorher einfach gar nicht gab. Also du warst auch glaube ich lange im Newsnet unterwegs und kennst wahrscheinlich diese ganzen Realnamendiskussionen, die im deutschen Newsnet geführt worden sind und wie das doch eigentlich anständig in der Diskussion zu sein sollte und eine Etikette und hier und so. Genau, und das war das eine. Das kannten wir im Westen. Und auf der anderen Seite gab es halt dieses Chaos, so jeder postet einfach irgendwas. Und alle sind Anonymous. Alle sind Anonymous und darauf wird dann geantwortet und fünf Minuten später ist der ganze Diskussionsfaden sowieso wieder verschwunden. Nun kann nicht jeder perfekt japanisch und die Amerikaner oder westlichen Leute, die sich da halt in Nitschaner Ruhe rumgetrieben haben, haben da wahrscheinlich auch selber irgendwie Meme produziert, ähnlich wie All Your Base I Belong to Us nur halt auf Japanisch. Und irgendwann war klar, wir brauchen ein Forum, wo halt nicht in Moonspeak, nicht in Japanisch diskutiert wird. Und das sollte halt doppelt so gut sein wie Nitschaner Ruhe, doppelt so gut sein wie 2chan, also hat man es dann 4chan genannt. Und das war dann das erste westliche Diskussionsforum und war halt auch sehr geprägt von dieser Anime- und Manga-Kultur, die dann halt immer wieder beliebt wurde. Auf der Republika hat auch der Gründer von diesem Diskussionsbord gesprochen und das lustigste war eigentlich, dass wir uns davor unterhalten haben und gesagt haben, ja, das wird ja auch genau so was gewesen sein. Irgendwie ich pubertiere einen 50-Jährigen, die gesagt haben, wir wollen irgendwie ein Forum haben, wo wir uns irgendwie Nacktbilder posten können. Und genau diesen Satz hat er dann halt auch später in seinem Vortrag gesagt, ja, also sich da angefangen habe, da war ich ja erst 15 und ich wollte ja einfach nur ein Forum für mich und meine Freunde haben, dass wir uns irgendwie gegenseitig Bilder posten können. Es ist halt wirklich immer genauso, wie man sich es hervorstellt. Und 4chan... Also 4chan hat ja auch dieses... Wie spricht man das nochmal richtig aus? Nitschanero? Nitschanero. Auch technisch kopiert. Also es funktioniert ähnlich, ist genauso aufgebaut. Ich meine, wenn du auf 4chan stößt, dann denkt man sich ja auch erstmal WTF, ja, was ist das denn? Also das ist irgendwie nach komischen Buchstaben sortiert, oben so mit Schrägstrichen eingedingst und jeder Buchstabe oder eine Zwei-Buchstaben-Kombination kodiert sozusagen den Inhalt. Ich weiß nicht, fallen ja ein paar Beispiele ein, was was ist. Also es gibt mittlerweile mehrere von diesen Chans. Also jeder macht dann halt noch irgendwie so... Ich meine jetzt bei 4chan konkret. Also es gibt mehrere, die nach diesem 4chan-Prinzip aufgebaut sind und die haben eigentlich fast immer ein Board drin, was B heißt. Bilibig könnte man auf Deutsch sagen. Random, also... B ist irgendwas. Und da gelten keine Regeln. Und da kann jeder posten, was er möchte. Und da gelten aber auch dann keine Regeln für die Moderatoren. Das heißt, die können löschen und bannen, wen sie möchten. Ja, warum auch immer. Da ist Wild West. Es gibt dann halt, ja, was weiß ich, es gibt irgendwie auch Bretter für Anime und Computerspiele und Kochen und Papierfalten und sowas. Aber...
Pornografie.
Ja. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob da sich so viele Leute rumtreiben. Ich glaube, bei diesem einen... Auch so dieser Anime, Porno, Hentai und dieser ganze Film. Ja, richtig, richtig, richtig. Aber die Seele von dem Ganzen ist halt irgendwie dieses Random Board B. Da tobt der Memekrieg. Genau.
Das ist auch die höchste Posting-Frequenz.
Und du hast gesagt, es wird ein ganzes Thread gelöscht. Das heißt, wie lange lebt denn jetzt so ein Thread normalerweise auf Fortschranken? Zwei bis fünf Minuten. Zwei bis fünf Minuten? Ist so meine Schätzung, ja.
Nee, also ich glaube, das ist schon länger. Also ich meine...
Kommt noch von natürlich auf die Uhrzeit und ob gerade Sommerferien sind.
Aber nicht länger als, naja, also...
Am nächsten Tag ist es weg.
Ja, also vielleicht maximal eine Stunde oder so.
Das heißt, da entsteht immer wieder irgendjemand postet, macht einen neuen Thread auf, oder was?
Richtig.
Postet was und dann antworten Leute da drauf.
Und dann, wer entscheidet dann, dass es verschwindet? Jemand, also jemand anderes macht einen neuen Thread auf, irgendwann verschwindet das dann von der Eingangsseite von diesem Board und irgendwann rutscht es so weit runter, dass es nicht mehr auftaucht und dann ist es weg.
Es ist so, man setzt so ein paar Knappheiten, also meinetwegen man setzt eine zeitliche Knappheit oder man setzt eine Knappheit, wie viel, wie lang darf der Thread werden oder wie viele Bilder dürfen da reingepostet werden. Genau, und die reguliert das dann selbst und das hat halt den Vorteil, dass man das nicht irgendwie ein Moderator jetzt nachträglich die einzelnen Threads irgendwie löschen muss. Das hat auch den Vorteil, dass beispielsweise, wenn da irgendwas flümmes ist in den Threads, dass man sich da auch nicht so sehr drum sorgen muss, weil das ist ja eh dann morgen weg wieder.
Das heißt, die expiren sozusagen von alleine.
Genau.
Die haben ja einfach eine lebensdauernde Vorteile und die weiß man auch vorher? Also die steht irgendwo, steht runter?
Ich glaube, dass das so ein bisschen unklar ist, ist auch ein der Vorteile. Ja, richtig.
Und wer sind diese Moderatoren? Kann man selber, wie wird man das, wenn alle Anonymous sind? Es gibt halt diesen Mut, der von sich behauptet, Christopher Poole mit Warendam zu heißen, ist fraglich, weil da auch jetzt sehr tief codiert auch verschiedene Meme von Ableitbar wären von dem Namen. Insofern weiß ich nicht, vielleicht heißt der wirklich so, vielleicht heißt er aber auch ganz anders. Der betreibt das Ding halt, das ist auch derjenige, bei dem dann das FBI anruft und sagt irgendwie, hier schon wieder auf der Vorderseite irgendwie Kinderpornografie, da muss er den Zweitart löschen. Und ja, von den Usern hat er halt Moderatorenrechte gegeben, fertig. Aber man weiß auch nicht, wer das jetzt genau ist. Okay, irgendjemand macht irgendwas. Irgendjemand macht irgendwas. Das ist eigentlich so das Hauptprinzip.
Dieses Chaos der Regeln ist halt glaube ich auch wichtig. Also wenn man das jetzt mit den endlosen Paragraphen- Diskussionen bei Wikipedia vergleicht, ist das halt dort so ein, wir wissen gar nicht genau, womit wir rechnen müssen.
Das heißt, damit da in diesem Forum überhaupt irgendetwas, was hervorbildet, ist diese Repetition. Und dieses immer wieder hervorbringen aufs Neue ist sozusagen zwingend notwendig, damit da überhaupt irgendetwas lebt.
Das andere ist sofort vergessen. Richtig. Richtig. Etwas muss erinnernswert sein, damit es am Leben bleibt.
Und was ist alles so da nun hervorgekommen? Na, also irgendwann, also die Regeln sind halt nicht existent da. Und ähnlich wie bei Twitter, wo halt jeder der Meinung ist, er selber benutzt Twitter richtig und alle andere benutzen es falsch. Wenn man halt keine Regeln vorgibt für einen Dienst, dann fangen die Leute selber an, Strukturen da reinzubauen. Irgendwann haben die Leute gesagt, es ist jetzt Samstag, jeder Samstag soll Katzentag sein, Cataday. It's Cataday, post some fucking cats. Die Leute sollen mal Bilder von Katzen posten. Und das haben die dann halt auch gemacht. Die haben jeden Samstag dann Katzenbilder gepostet. Und irgendwann fing jemand an, hat gesagt... Wir sind bei Fortschauen. Diese Katzenbilder wurden dann entsprechend umgestaltet. Das heißt, man hat diesen Katzen an Laser-Ogen gemacht oder so was mit Photoshop. Irgendwann kam jemand drauf und hat gesagt, das wäre doch total lustig, wenn die Katzen jetzt mal sagen würden und hat dann halt noch so sprechblasenmäßig Text auf diese Katzenbilder draufgepappt, dass die halt irgendwie sich im Internet slangen oder in gebrochenen Englisch, die können halt nicht richtig gut schreiben, die Katzen, weil das sind halt Katzen, dass die halt dann in so einer Art Leadspeak sich dann unterhalten. Und das hat so vielen Leuten gefallen, dass dieses Meme halt überlebt hat. Und irgendwann dann ein Programmierer aus Hawaii, der gerade arbeitslos geworden ist, gedacht hat, anscheinend fahren die Leute im Internet total auf niedliche Katzenbilder mit lustigen Sprüchen ab. Ich mach da mal eine Seite auf und hat dann nach einem Katzenbild benannt, die Seite I Can Has Cheeseburger gegründet und hat da angefangen halt diese eigentlich aus Fortschern stammenden Katzenbilder zu sammeln, die von einem Ketter daherkommen. Und die meisten Leute kennen das heute unter dem Begriff Loicats und unter Loicats steht es, glaube ich, auch in der Wikipedia. Da sieht man halt den Unterschied. Also ursprünglich war das einfach Cataday. Wer den Begriff kennt, der kommt dann eher wahrscheinlich aus dieser Fortschern-Anarchie-Image-Bord-Richtung. Wer das als Loicat kennt, der kommt wahrscheinlich eher aus der Richtung, dass er das halt in einer verfeinerten Form schon als Teil der Internetkultur über diese I Can Has Cheeseburger-Seite oder so kennengelernt hat.
Dann noch einen allgemeinen Begriff für dieses Format Bildfotum vor allem, aufgesetzter Text, das Image-Macro.
Genau.
Gibt's halt auch noch ganz viele andere Sorten. Loicats sind sozusagen diejenigen, die am meisten bekannt ist. Und ja. Was sind andere? Es gibt halt ganz viele populäre Sprüche, die man halt immer auf irgendwie auch wieder andere populäre Bilder postet.
Also zum Beispiel gibt es diesen Effekt, man liest irgendwas im Internet und denkt sich, oh Gott, das darf doch nicht wahr sein und schlägt irgendwie die Hand vor das Gesicht. Fail. Fail, sagt man dann. Und diese Geste des Hand-vors-Gesichts-Schlagen, Face-Palm. Also Hand, äh, Gesicht und Handrücken. Und ja, das ist kein englisches Wort, aber das wurde dann halt als Neologismus neu geprägt.
Jetzt ist es eins.
Jetzt ist es eins. Genauso wie Fail halt auch früher mal ein Verb war und jetzt ist es halt auch ein Nomen. Das ist Fail oder sogar Attektiv oder so. Ja, wie auch immer.
Allgemeiner.
Das ist auch schon unklar und auch nicht mehr wichtig.
Das ist einfach Fail. Man hat halt solche Sachen, die entstehen dann in sehr obskuren Ecken im Netz, wie beispielsweise 4Trend, und die werden dann wirklich richtig Mainstream. Also gab es irgendwie diese Gefichte, dass jetzt auch Fernsehmoderatoren in den USA in Nachrichtensendungen oder so einfach nur Fail sagen und solche Sachen, wo das überhaupt nicht irgendwie ihren Sprachcodes entsprechen dürfte. Das ist halt so diese...
Das ist ja noch recht neu mit dem Fail. Das gibt es ja nun gerade mal, na, ein Jahr, anderthalb? Zwei? Also Fail-Block gibt es noch nicht so lange. Fail-Block ist halt auch, genau, also von den Leuten, die I Can't Hashtes-Cheeseburger machen, und es ist halt sozusagen der zweite Versuch, diese Image-Makrokultur von Fortschein in ein kommerzielles Produkt zu machen. Aber haben die das nicht erst sozusagen, also wurde diese ganze Fail-Geschichte nicht durch das Fail-Block überhaupt erst...
Das war einfach ein weiterer Machtverstärker, aber man kann halt immer nicht so genau sagen, daran nach.
Man kann sagen, dass es ganz klar von Fortschein kommt. Aus dieser Ursuppe Fortschein. Und irgendwann wurde das da rausgefischt und dann gibt es dieses Fail-Block jetzt.
Man muss sich das halt wirklich... Bei Fortschein, Fortschein ist wirklich ein Ort, von dem man jetzt nicht wirklich sagen kann, den halten wir jetzt als große repräsentativen Internetraum stolz überall dorthin, wo Leute über Internetkultur reden, weil er halt einerseits sehr obskur ist und andererseits sehr krass in gewissen Dingen. Und der ist sozusagen nicht wirklich gesellschaftsfähig.
Also so eine typische Vorderseite von Fortschein könnte halt sein, irgendwie ein Posting mit lauter Hakenkreuzen, darunter japanischer Tentakel-Porn und als nächstes dann ein niedliches Katzenbild. So, das ist... Ja, letztendlich ist es dann halt auch das Internet so, ne? Nazis, Perverse und Katz und Liebhaber. Eigentlich ist das Ganze so ein bisschen so ein Waschsalon. Also der ganze Schmutz des Internets wird in die Waschmaschinen da rein geworfen. Man sitzt dann da vorne und schaut die ganze Zeit dabei zu, wie das, also die ganze Zeit im Kreis vor sich hingewaschen wird. Dabei erscheint immer mal wieder so ein Bild an dieser Glasscheibe, ist aber auch gleich wieder weg. Manchmal ist es eine Katze. Manchmal ist es eine Katze und manchmal geht man wieder raus aus dem Waschsalon und glaubt, irgendwas gesehen zu haben und hat dann einfach so ein Stempel in seiner Erinnerung, mit dem man dann weiterzieht.
Richtig, ganz genau. Und aus dieser völlig merkwürdigen Ecke entstehen dann halt Sachen, die sich wirklich extrem in den Mainstream ausbreiten. Also man hat dort ganz, ganz viel, was nicht gesellschaftsfähig ist, aber dann entsteht halt eine große kulturell generierende Kraft, die dann tatsächlich einige Sachen produziert, die von allen Menschen dann plötzlich angenommen werden, obwohl sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht wissen würden wollen, wie das wirklich entstanden ist. Und das ist halt, deshalb ist so, ist so Fortran wahrscheinlich gerade durch seine Gesellschaftsunfähigkeit und dadurch, dass es mehr so eine Art sehr unangenehmes Unterbewusstsein des Netzes halt in voller Breite durcharbeitet, zugleich so die Maschine, sozusagen die Intelligenzmaschine, die ganz, ganz viel Mainstream-Internet-Kultur generiert, ohne dass man das unbedingt darauf zurückführen würde wollen.
Also es ist halt so ein Treub paradies, das ist halt, es gibt dieses schöne Bild von normale zivilisierte Person plus Anonymität plus Publikum gleich Arschloch. Also irgendwas scheint da mit normalen Menschen zu passieren, sobald sie ein Forum bekommen und anonym da halt irgendwie rum renten können. Entweder werden sie besonders grausam oder übertreten Grenzen oder die Kreativität fängt an zu sprudeln. Ja, also es gibt halt dann nichts mehr, was einen an Regeln einengt.
Es ist so, da ändert sich halt tatsächlich so das Verhältnis von Identität von Mensch und von Kultur. Man hat halt eine Landschaft, in der eigentlich die Träger und die Rezipienten und auch die Produzenten von Kultur so ganz anders strukturiert sind, als sie das halt bisher kulturgefichtlich meist waren. Also einerseits die Formate, in denen sich Kultur verbreitet, sind halt ganz andere. Das heißt, es sind halt irgendwie kleine Reizbilder und es sind irgendwie winzige Textzeilen und so weiter. Und die werden plötzlich...
Mini-Clips. Es ist halt nicht mehr der abendfüllende Spielfilm oder der große Roman, sondern es ist halt ein Katzenbild und ein Zehn-Sekunden-Flash-Video.
Genau. Früher war es so, man hat irgendwie so eine pyramidale Struktur und da schreibt dann irgendjemand ein großes Werk und das wird dann massenweise vervielfältig auf den Markt geworfen und verbreitet sich dadurch. Und jetzt hat man halt mehr dieses... Es gibt ganz, ganz viele winzige kleine Teile, die halt zusammengewürfelt werden und die sich chaotisch weiterverbreiten und die gar nicht diese klassischen Verbreitungsstrukturen beanspruchen und die auch gar nicht beispielsweise es notwendig haben, sich über so etwas zu verkaufen, wie ich habe jetzt hier einen Autor und dieser Autor schreibt ganz tolle Bücher und ich weiß immer, das nächste Buch, was er schreibt, werde ich auch kaufen, sondern es funktioniert halt völlig unabhängig von solchen Identitätsstrukturen, so dass wir jetzt irgendwie hier einen Menschen haben und hier haben wir das Publikum und hier haben wir den Autor. Das verwässert da alles völlig in dieser Arena.
Was sind denn so eure Lieblings-Meme, die sich so, die ihr selber vielleicht auch schon mal weitergetragen habt? Oder tragt ihr einfach alles weiter, was euch für die Füße geworfen wird? Ich trag alles weiter, was mir vor die Füße geworfen wird. Gerne auch immer das Neueste und dann halt auch so gerne so lange, bis es halt irgendwie echt keinen Spaß mehr macht. Aber warum machst du das? Ich finde das halt einerseits so von dem Hintergrund fasziniert, was das ist. Also es ist eine ganz andere Art, Kultur zu machen und Kultur zu konsumieren und zu produzieren. Aber andererseits ja, genauso wie es irgendwie dazugehört, schwarze T-Shirts als Hacker zu tragen, fühle ich mich halt irgendwie dieser Netzkultur auch zugehörig. Und ja, es ist dann halt wie am Anfang dieses Schibulett, wenn der andere versteht, was ich sage, mit All Your Base, A Belong to Us, dann weiß ich, okay, wir sind vom gleichen Stamm. Was ist denn dein Lieblings-Meme? Gibt es so was? Mehrfach Nennung möglich. Also muss ich jetzt hier nicht auf das Beste, weil das ist sicherlich schwierig, aber was sind denn so Sachen, die dir besonders gut gefallen haben? Außer an denen jetzt, die wir schon gemacht haben. Vorhin hattet ihr irgendwas mit dem Einhorn? Ja, also ich kann auch irgendwie nach mehreren Jahren Bombardement mit niedlichen Katzenbildern immer noch über loyal Cats lachen. Immer noch. Ja, da ist viel zu holen. Ja, das geht immer gut. Und wo sich die Hunde komischerweise nicht so durchgesetzt haben, habe ich den Eindruck, oder? Ich habe das Gefühl, Netzmenschen haben eher eine Affinität zu Katzen-Azonen. Aber das ist jetzt auch irgendwie völlig aus dem Bauch raus.
Das ist, glaube ich, was mit der rein interpretierten Intelligenzfunktion von Katzengesichtern versus Hundegesichtern zu tun.
Ist es nicht eher so, dass die Katze auch so ein bisschen für dieses renitente, anarchische Modell steht? Ich meine, Hunde, das sind immer so diese Viecher, die laufen hier hinterher. Die machen alles, was du sagst. Aber eine Katze sträubt die Haare, zeigt die Krallen und macht dann einfach, was sie will.
Ja, ja, das meine ich ja damit auch. Das ist halt eine Katze, da kann man halt mehr eine eigenwillige, eigenständige Intelligenz rein etablieren.
Also, du passt das sozusagen mit, also diese Eigenständigkeit, mit Intelligenz? Intelligenz heißt eigenständig sein?
Na, Intelligenz, jetzt müsste man den Begriff Intelligenz definieren. Aber Intelligenz heißt dann zumindest eine größere Eigenständigkeit, beispielsweise im Umgang mit der Welt und eventuell auch eine größere sich verselbstständigen gegenüber der Welt. Und das haben dann halt die Katzen, die sozusagen zu deren Gefichte quasi dazugehört, dass man immer gerne rein interpretiert, dass sie sehr egoistisch sind und sich quasi sehr hedonistisch die Welt um sich herum aneignen, eher als die sehr hörigen und eigentlich fast mafinell funktionierenden Hunde.
Es gibt natürlich auch so Meme, also irgendwann ist das halt auch, ich glaube, der Grund, warum du überhaupt angefangen hast, darüber nachzudenken, Podcast zum Thema Meme zu machen war, weil das halt irgendwann im letzten Jahr so dermaßen in die Öffentlichkeit gebrochen ist durch diese Aktion Anonymous gegen Scientology. Wir haben schon vor zwei Jahren darüber gesprochen, diesen Podcast zu machen. Richtig, richtig, richtig. Der Wunsch existiert schon länger. Ja, das hat alles natürlich dazu beigetragen. Das ist auch ein wichtiges Element, was wir noch mal reden. Und das, würde ich zum Beispiel sagen, ist gar nicht mal so richtig mein Lieblings-Meme, dieses dann auf die Straße gehen und demonstrieren gegen Scientology. Das müssen wir noch mal aufrollen, was da überhaupt passiert ist. Das Ganze hat doch angefangen mit diesem absurden Video von Tom Cruise. Richtig. Ja, oder was weiß ich, womit es angefangen hat. Aber das war so das, woran manche es festmachten. Also dieses Tom Cruise-Video, was so eine Art internes Coaching-Video ist von Scientology, das er da dabei ist, das weiß man ja seit langer Zeit. Und ich habe es, glaube ich, auch irgendwann mal in seiner Länge gesehen und das erredet fünf Minuten lang total einen Stuss. Aber mit einem irren Blinzeln in den Augen. Ja, also wirklich der helle Wahnsinn so. Das wäre es wahrscheinlich gewesen und dieses Video wäre so als weitere Anekdote von Beklopptheit einfach wieder auch in so eine normale Vergessenheit geraten, nur hat dann Scientology wieder diesen Fehler gemacht, dass die Redistribution dieses Videos zu verhindern. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, auf welche Art und Weise. Auf jeden Fall sind sie da aktiv geworden. Das haben sie ja schon immer ganz gerne gemacht und auch früher schon damit eigentlich auf die Schnauze gefallen. Und dann gab es auf einmal den Widerstand. Dieser Widerstand formte sich in 4chan. Naja, der formte sich irgendwie in dieser Chan-Image-Sportkultur. Okay, reden wir von den Image-Sports vielleicht als kulturelle Größe, sodass er sozusagen auch eine, ja, ich gehe mal da von einer relativ jungen Nutzerschaft aus auch, ja, 14-jährige Jungs. 14-jährige Jungs.
Der Erwachsene, die 14-jährige Jungs spielen.
Genau. Oder so. Oder Mädchen. So, und da waren sie dann dagegen. Und dann gab es auf einmal in dieser anonymen Wolke den Wunsch des gelebten Widerstandes.
Richtig, richtig.
Und halt die Idee war, was auch immer wieder, also das war halt dann schon ein selbstreflexives Memen in Fortschern drin. So, wir sind anonymous, wir sind viele, wir haben kein Gesicht, wir sind machtvoll, wir vergessen nie, wir können alle vernichten und so, ne?
Also auch so, ah, ein bisschen auch pubertäres Allmacht.
Ja, genau. Ihr könnt uns gar nichts, genau.
Richtig.
Und dann irgendwann fing das an über IRC und Wikis und diverse anderen. Plötzlich entstand da eine Kultur und eine Idee und ein Meme an sich, nämlich wir zeigen Scientology. Die werden uns jetzt irgendwie kennenlernen. Wir haben einen neuen Feind. Genau. Und dann gab es ein YouTube-Video, wo halt eine düstere Landschaft gezeigt wird und dann eine Computerstimme sagte dazu, hallo, Führer von Scientology, wir haben euer Tram jetzt lange genug zugesehen und wir glauben, dass die einzige Lösung, die es jetzt noch gibt, ist, eure Organisation mit Stumpf und Stil zu vernichten und so weiter. Also wirklich auch so in so einem Terroristenstil gehalten. Aber auf der anderen Seite standen da halt wirklich Leute dahinter, deren Lebensinhalt es ist, Kätzchenbilder und Nacktfotos zu posten.
Na gut, aber der Teil der Kultur ist natürlich auch, dass man so ein paar, sagen wir mal, böse Streiche auch spielt. Also dass man sich organisiert. Lasst uns mal dieses Forum stürmen. Das ist meinetwegen jetzt hier irgendwie ein Forum von Leuten, deren Lebensstil wir doof finden. Und jetzt lasst uns mal da stürmen und die alle verarfen und die alle zuspammen mit Zeugs, was irgendwie sie provoziert. Oder beziehungsweise auch sehr vieles in die Richtung, oh, wir haben hier jemanden, den mögen wir nicht. Lasst uns doch mal jetzt eine Seite hochziehen, wo jetzt irgendwie ganz viele Bilder mit demontiert werden, dass der irgendwie in Fuhlenpornos mitspielt oder so. Und so dieses Internet-Hate-Maschinen. Und wir sind sehr kompetent darin, Sachen, die wir nicht mögen, richtig doll kaputt zu machen auf alle Weisen, wie das mit Internet-Kulturkompetenz geht. Und aus diesem Macht, daraus entsteht sozusagen ein Machtgefühl. Und dieses Machtgefühl, was wir lange Zeit immer nur angewendet haben, auf sehr harmlose Weise bzw. auf nicht wirklich produktive Weise. Das wollen wir jetzt mal bündeln, um zu zeigen, wir können da auch mal richtig etwas in die Gesellschaft hineintragen.
Am Anfang war es halt gar nicht so koordiniert. Also das waren halt nur Denial-of-Service-Attacken gegen Scientology-Seiten, Scherzanrufe bei Scientology und die üblichen halt 20 Kilometer schwarzes Faxpapier und so weiter, solche Sachen halt. Und irgendwann war das halt auch selber ein Meme geworden. Anonymous kämpft gegen Scientology und jemand, der sich schon seit lange damit beschäftigt mit Scientology und was das für eine Organisation ist und welche Repressionsmaßnahmen die machen und so weiter, der hat dann halt genau die Arena betreten, wo Anonymous tobte, nämlich hat selber ein YouTube-Video eingestellt und hat gesagt, Kinder, ich erzähle euch jetzt mal, wie das hier richtig funktioniert. Und hat halt gesagt, was Scientology mit Kritikern veranstaltet und ihr müsst da und da aufpassen und koordiniert das mal alles ein bisschen. Mir fällt gerade der Name von dem Herrn nicht.
Weißbeardman.
Ja, ja, genau. Weißbeardman, der Herr mit dem weißen Bart, hat sicherlich auch, also, ist glaube ich auch sehr, sehr bekannt in dieser Anti-Scientology-Bewegung, so von der wissenschaftlichen Seite her. Und der Weißbeardman wurde dann selber zu mir, wurde dann halt auch immer wieder reposted in 4chan und anderen Image-Boards.
His words are wise, his face is beard.
Und das führte dann dazu, dass diese ganze Aktion dann halt auch koordinierter wurde. Plötzlich wurden Demos angekündigt und, richtig, Demos veranstaltet. Ja, und plötzlich war das halt eine Netzbewegung geworden, ähnlich wie wir das hier in Deutschland mit der Bewegung gegen Wahlcomputer oder sonstige Sachen halt gesehen haben. Aber halt erst mal aus dem totalen Chaos hatte sich da irgendwas geformt, aus der totalen Anarchie von diesen Imageboards.
Wobei ich zu dem Weißbierd-Man auch noch sagen möchte, da gab es halt, der Dialog lief quasi so ab, dass er halt YouTube-Videos gepostet hat, in denen er in seinem Webcam geredet hat, an diese Körperanonymous. Das war halt so eine sehr seltsame, sehr Science-Fiction-mäßig Situation, weil man halt diesen einzelnen normalen Mensch hat, der so eine komöfe posthumane Cyber-Konfiguration ständig redet, als wäre das irgendwie ein Mensch, aber auch gleichzeitig irgendwie eine Gruppe und so, die man nicht so genau verorten kann. Der hat sozusagen mit denen durchaus geredet, wie man mit einem Mensch redet und es kam auch genauso Antworten. Genau. Also in den Kommentaren, in den Kommentarsektionen und so weiter, bei YouTube, man lästert ja immer gerne gegen die YouTube-Kommentarsektionen, wobei die YouTube-Kommentarsektionen sich eigentlich ähnlich lesen, wie sich beispielsweise im Imageboard Text-Frets lesen, hat halt dieses Chaos-Bewusstsein geantwortet und man hat dann natürlich auch Kommentare immer wieder gehabt, die halt irgendwie gegen ihn gerichtet waren. Aber einfach in der Masse ist dann halt groteskerweise ein produktiver Dialog tatsächlich entstanden, was man nicht erwarten würde, dass so aus irgendwie doven Spruchwitzen und irgendwie versuchen, irgendwie Leute irgendwie zu verarfen, tatsächlich so eine Intelligenz emergiert, die fähig ist, einen Dialog zu führen mit jemandem. Das war ein sehr spannender Moment.
Und dann sprach Anonymous, es werde Licht und es wartet Licht. Und plötzlich war es halt dann auch eine wirklich existierende Gruppe, die auch wirklich demonstriert hat. Und in Los Angeles gab es irgendwie riesen Demonstrationen. Ein paar Leute haben sich auch in Berlin gefunden und in Düsseldorf und so weiter. Weltweit kann man sagen. Weltweit, ja, natürlich weltweit. Obwohl der Protest dann konkret so aussah, dass sich halt verschiedene Leute vor diesen Scientology-Zentralen wiedergefunden haben. Teilweise halt, na ja, also eben dann auch anonym mit Masken. Genau. Diese Maske aus VW Vandetta. Genau, diese Guy Fawkes-Maske ist dann sehr populär geworden, die in dieser Form nur so im Film war, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Ich glaube ja, ja.
Richtig.
Also so stellvertretend für diese Versteckung von diesem Guy Fawkes, also die Verkleidung von Guy Fawkes. Das war dann sozusagen das, oder ist jetzt mittlerweile, einfach das Sinnbild für anonym sein. Auch wieder sehr interessant, wie das so im Kreis gegangen ist. Und Guy Fawkes dann wiederum natürlich auch als Sinnbild des Widerstands gegen irgendeinen mächtigen Apparat. In dem Fall halt. Und was haben sie gemacht? Sie haben dann auch tatsächlich Scientology bestraft, indem sie Rick Astley-Musik gespielt haben. Genau, da gibt es dann auch schöne... Das ist ja auch so ein Ding, nicht? Muss man natürlich noch mal erwähnen, auch wenn es viele Leute kennen.
Aber noch mal zu den Masken. Das ist halt auch so eine spannende Geschichte, weil das war sozusagen direkt auch so ein bisschen auf Scientology passend, weil Scientology halt diese Gefichte hat, dass Leute, die als ihre Gegner auftreten und auch öffentlich irgendwie was versuchen zu machen, sich herauspicken. Die brauchen sozusagen jemanden, den sie herauspicken können und dessen Leben sie dann halt durch diverse Strategien erfähren können, indem sie halt einen gigantischen Rechtsapparat, einen gigantischen Öffentlichkeitsapparat gegen diese Leute ausrichten, bei deren Arbeitgeber anrufen und sie dort schlechtlegen.
Um ein Exempel zu statuieren und andere Leute abzuschrecken.
Genau, und das funktioniert halt sehr gut, wenn Leute als klare bürgerliche Identitäten mit einem Namen auftreten. Und das funktioniert halt nicht so gut, wenn man als einen Haufen auftritt, der irgendwie sagt, wir tragen alle dieselbe Maske. Niemand von uns hat eine bürgerliche Identität. Wenn irgendwie der Polizist kommt und sagt, lasst uns gerne nicht mit dem Anführer reden, können wir auf niemanden verweisen, weil wir irgendwie so das FLEV-Mob-mäßig irgendwie spontan organisiert sind und niemanden haben, der uns sagt, was wir tun. Und das ist halt, da hatte sozusagen diese Struktur der Anonymität halt, traf da aufeinander mit etwas, was damit eigentlich nicht umgehen konnte. Und ich glaube, das ist halt auch so allgemein, was auch glaube ich noch, was glaube ich auch sehr gut zu sehen ist, ich glaube in Korea gab es jetzt irgendwie so diese Gefichte, Leute müssen sich mit ihrer bürgerlichen Identität klar greifbar identifizieren, wenn sie beispielsweise bei YouTube Videos posten wollen, was halt so eine Konfliktlinie ist, die sich glaube ich noch verstärken wird. Also dieses, wir funktionieren eigentlich als Identität von postindividuell und haben es gar nicht nötig, uns irgendwie auf einen Autoren, aber auch auf einen Verantwortlichen zu stützen und dieses andere, wir brauchen einen klar greifbaren Namen, den wir verantwortlich machen können und den wir belohnen oder bestrafen können. Und das ist halt so, dieser Kultur, die ist quasi genau gegenstrukturiert und das war halt bei diesem Scientology-Protest, hat das sehr gut funktioniert, weil die hat dann noch so klare Anweisungen, wenn ihr dorthin geht, behaltet eure Masken auf, nehmt die, geht auch wirklich mit den Masken auf wieder auseinander, also geht dann nicht irgendwie zusammen dann irgendwie danach ein Trinken-Kollektiv und setzt dann die Masken ab, sondern idealerweise passt auf, dass irgendwie vielleicht sogar ein paar Scientologen vielleicht unter euch sind, auch mit Masken auf, aber dass die trotzdem nicht den Moment erleben, wo ihr jetzt plötzlich euch wieder in klare identifizierbare Name-Facts zurück verwandelt, also Leute, die einen Namen tragen.
Naja, also da herrscht halt ein rauer Umgangston und da werden halt alle erstmal grundsätzlich als Schwuchtellen, als Facts bezeichnet, damit diese Beleidigung da schon mal abgekänzelt ist. Das heißt, ja.
Das heißt, alle Begriffe, die irgendwie jemand identifizieren können, werden immer an Facts angehangen.
New Facts sind dann die neulige und Old Facts sind die alten usw. Und hat jetzt diese Memekultur der bösen Image-Sports mit ihren ganzen anonymen Jünglingen, die gegen die Weltstruktur aufbegehren, jetzt irgendeine Rückwirkung auf die normale Gesellschaft, die sich schon abzeichnet? Oder ist das alles so ein Phänomen? Also im Moment beobachte ich halt gerade bei diesen Image-Sports oder so, gibt es halt eher so eine Gegenkultur zu diesem riesen Ding. Also plötzlich war halt 4chan und war halt Anonymous in allen Schlagzeilen. Da gab es halt richtig Fernsehberichte darüber, über diese Scientology-Proteste und ja, dann hat das Internet halt zurückgeschlagen. Da haben die Image-Sports gesagt, das sind irgendwie Moral-Facts, also Leute, die halt irgendwie Moral haben und denen es gar nicht mehr um den Spaß und die Loyals geht, sondern irgendwie haben die eine eigene Agenda, die die verfolgen und das ist nicht mehr die Anarchie, die ich mal haben wollte. Und das ist halt so jetzt die Gegenbewegung. Also mittlerweile kennt wirklich jeder dieses Phänomen und wir haben jetzt auch bei diesem Amoklauf vor einigen Wochen das Phänomen erlebt, dass wirklich ein baden-württembergischer Innenminister sich hingestellt hat und auf einer Pressekonferenz im Image-Sport- Slang verfasst eine Nachricht verließt. Wo er halt dann, naja, die deutsche Übersetzung von Anonymous ist halt Bernd, kommt wahrscheinlich von Bernd das Brot oder so. Es gibt ein Image-Sport namens Crowd-Chan, für Deutsche halt, für Crowds. Und da sind alle Bernd. Da sind alle Bernd. Und Bernd hat dann sozusagen angekündigt, dass er dann in Winnin in Armok liegt. Ich habe es satt, Bernd. Ich habe dieses Lotterleben satt. Ich werde morgen in meine Schule gehen und dort erstmal gepflegt grillen. Also das sind Meme, die man halt dann irgendwie kennt, wenn man in diesem Crowd-Chan da irgendwie rumhängt. Also das gepflegt grillen ist ein Euphemismus für Selbstmordbegehen. Selbstmord? Nicht andere Leute grillen im Sinne von Töten, sondern eigentlich eher eine Selbstmord-Ankündigung. Letztendlich ist es auch wirklich, also es fällt mir schon schwer, über diesen Schwachsinn irgendwie ernsthaft zu reden. Ja, ja, ich finde es nur so ein bisschen zu aufzufächern.
Das war doch auch irgendwie fake.
Das war natürlich ein Fake. Genau, das fand gar nicht im Board statt, sondern es hat nur jemand den Boardthread genommen. Soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, hat dann das HTML einfach geändert, das auf seinem Browserlokal angezeigt, da von Screenshot gemacht und das war dann das, was dann ins Board gepostet. In dasselbe? Natürlich. Aber wer hat es dann da wieder rausgetragen, dass es so schnell Welle machen konnte?
Das ist halt, das Wichtigste ist halt erstmal der Vorwurf, den man eigentlich gemacht hat gegenüber diesem Innenminister beispielsweise. Der eigentliche Vorwurf des Missverständnisses ist halt, dass was in diesem Imageboard stattfindet, per Definition nicht verifizierbar ist. Da ist sozusagen alles, da jeder anonymen alles rein schreiben kann und rein fälschen kann, auch beispielsweise, kann man das nicht als Beweismittel nehmen, wenn da irgendwas aus diesem Forum kommt. Wenn das jetzt nicht irgendwie anders wo auch verifizierbar ist, dass es alles per Definition ist, ist das erstmal Quatsch, was in so einem Forum drinnen steht und es hat sozusagen keine Rückbehauptung, dass es wahr wäre. Die kann es erst aufstellen, wenn es irgendwie außerhalb eines solchen Threads auch noch verifizierbar ist. Und den Moment, wo man sagt, wir nehmen jetzt als Beweismittel eine Geschichte, die erzählt wird in so einem Forum oder ein Bild, was in so einem Forum auftaucht, setzt man sich in die Brennnesseln. Und das war eigentlich der Vorwurf, dass man das doch nicht so tun kann, als wäre so ein Chan eine brauchbare Beweisquelle. Und das ist halt dieser völlig andere Umgang mit Kultur, dieses wir generieren halt Texte mehr oder weniger automatisch und führen uns nicht darum, woher die kommen oder so. Das lässt sich halt genauso verkoppeln mit diesem völlig veränderten Wahrheitsanspruch.
Richtig. Also es steht bei 4chan auch tatsächlich im B Diskussionsbrett drin. Alles, was hier ist, ist Teil einer Fiktion. Nur Idioten glauben das. Und ja, so muss man das halt auch wirklich sehen. Und ich denke mal, dass es dann einfach mangelnde Kulturkompetenz von diesem Innenminister gewesen, wenn der sich hingestellt hat und gesagt hätte, also ich habe da jetzt heute im Bus ein paar Jugendliche auf der letzten Bank sich unterhalten hören. Wenn er so was vorgetragen hätte, hätte er gesagt, also, Entschuldigung, das ist doch keine verlässliche Quelle. Aber sobald es im Internet gedruckt erscheint, weißt du? Genau, im Internet gedruckt.
Wobei auch diese Geschichte mit alles, was hier steht, ist fiktional. Es kommt nicht mal so sehr darauf an, sondern dass es völlig egal ist. Es kommt nicht darauf an, es ist jetzt nicht die Behauptung, dass wir jetzt eine Geschichte erfinden und wir denken uns jetzt was aus, sondern es ist einfach, hier werden einfach 1 und 0 generiert und die werden quasi generiert, ohne dass es irgendjemand interessiert, ob das jetzt verifizierbar ist oder nicht.
Gibt es denn Beispiele für Internet-Meme, die jetzt, sagen wir mal, es jetzt auch schon so aus der Popularität im Internet hinaus geschafft haben?
Ja, Fail hatten wir ja vorhin. Rickroll müsste man, glaube ich, allgemein nochmal erläutern, wenn das nicht, glaube ich, inzwischen jeder.
Nö, wir können ja gerne auch mal alles erläutern. Ich glaube, es gibt auch mal sehr viele Missverständnisse.
Also Rickroll ist halt, ich glaube, es kommt auch aus Fortune, da gab es halt diese Geschichte, dass man gerne auch Leute verarft hat, indem man halt links auf etwas gepostet hat, was halt nicht das Versprochene war. Und da gab es dann, ich weiß, glaube ich, Duckroll oder so war das. Man hat dann irgendwie so ein, man hat halt irgendwie einen Link auf etwas gepostet, was halt nicht dem entsprach, was man da versprochen hat. Und das war quasi ein allgemeinen Roll.
Genau, das war halt meistens ein Bild von einer Holzente mit Rädern. Also da stand dann irgendwie hier, downloaden, die neue Version von dem Computerspiel so und so, kommt morgen erst raus, klickt da drauf und dann kam halt ein Bild von einer Ente mit Rädern dran. Die Duckroll war das. Und irgendwann reichte das halt nicht mehr und man brauchte halt ein Video dazu. Und hat dann halt gemäß dem Motto B, random, irgendeins genommen und hat dann halt aus den 80er Jahren produziert von Stock, Adgen und Waterman von Rick Astley, Never Gonna Give You Up genommen. Wo es damals so ein ziemlicher Hit war. Ja, so ein Pop-Schlager halt. Aber hätte auch jetzt jeder wieder vergessen.
Ein völlig egales Dokument.
Genau, so ein affiges Video, wo er da so ein bisschen rumscharvenzelt und rumtanzt und noch ein paar Mädels dazwischen, noch ein paar andere Boys und alle tanzen die ganze Zeit. Und das ist einfach Herzschmerz und Schnulz. Richtig. Text ist völlig nicht sankt. Musik ist irgendwie halt industriell produziert. Aber jetzt wurde es auf einmal aufgeladen durch diese Injektion aus dem Netz. Ja, da stand dann halt hier Beweismittel für das und das, was dich gerade interessiert. Hier ist der Link. Klickst du drauf und du siehst Rick Astley tanzen. Und man weiß eigentlich in dem Moment, also heute weiß man, wenn man da draufklickt, hat man verloren. Weil man ist verarscht worden. Man ist verarscht worden, man ist sozusagen auf das Glatteis geführt worden. Bloß wird man halt nicht mehr auf das Glatteis geführt, sondern man wird halt auf YouTube geführt und darf sich halt Rick Astley zum hundertsten Mal anschauen.
Wobei das ja noch die harmlosste Variante ist. Also ähnlich wie bei allgemein bei diesem, man verarft Leute durch Links, gab es natürlich auch einfach, dass man Links auf Seiten bei, beispielsweise, gesetzt hat, die das Video zeigen und auch den Browser kapern, damit man das nicht wegklicken kann und dann irgendwie. Also das ist halt, da war auch irgendwie dieses, wir wollen dir auch wirklich ein bisschen Leid an tun. Und das Video ist halt auch irgendwie sehr käsig und man ist dann genötigt eigentlich, das zu Ende zu gucken und einem wird halt Zeit gestohlen und einem wird Produktivität gestohlen, die man genötigt wird, sich mit Nonsens auseinanderzusetzen. Das ist auch so eine kleine Verletzung, die einem da beigeführt wird und die dann halt als, die dann irgendwann aber tatsächlich so populär wird, dass Leute zwar sagen, es geht ihnen furchtbar auf die Nerven einerseits, aber andererseits hat man so einen Drang, es tatsächlich immer wieder von neuem weiterzutragen und zu reproduzieren. Das ist halt ähnlich wie bei den, wie bei so Ekel-Memen wie dem Goatse, dass halt irgendwie eigentlich man das niemals ernsthaft zumuten möchte und man es auch selber eigentlich nicht wieder sehen möchte, aber es trotzdem nicht totzukriegen ist, unerklärlicherweise.
Und das Ganze endet ja damit, dass YouTube am 1. April dann tatsächlich dieses Meme selbst aufgegriffen hat. Also letztes Jahr war das. Da haben sie auf der Eingangsseite von YouTube gibt es dann immer hier neue Videos oder Featured-Video und jeder Link auf der Eingangsseite von YouTube landete immer auf Rick Astley.
Was hat Rick Astley da vorne ja auch profitiert?
Richtig. Und das ging halt dann wirklich auch in die Mainstream-Kultur rein. Also es gab letztes Jahr, es gibt immer im Herbst diese Thanksgiving-Parade in New York von Macy's, wo halt, ähnlich wie im Kölner Karneval, Riesenwagen halt durch die Straßen fahren und schmeißen die auch Kamelle? Ich weiß nicht, oder ist das mehr so ein rheinisches Meme? Auf jeden Fall wird im Fernsehen übertragen und alle Kinder gehen dahin. Und da gab es dann von einem Kinderfernsehsender, glaube ich, einen Motivwagen. Und plötzlich ging da die Musik aus und auftrat Rick Astley und Rick rollte live die gesamte Fernseh-Nation und halt alle Zuschauer dieser Thanksgiving-Parade. Ah, da kam das. Ich habe das Video gesehen, ich wusste bloß nicht genau, wo das gezeigt wurde. Er machte halt auch... Interessant, obwohl er ja eigentlich meinte, er würde ja auf diesen Zug gar nicht aufspringen wollen. Also am Anfang hat es ihn halt sehr, sehr genervt und er hat halt auch gedacht, er würde damit jetzt angegriffen werden oder es hätte jemand persönlich was gegen ihn. Und irgendwann hat er gemerkt, okay, es geht eigentlich letztendlich sogar gar nicht um mich, es geht doch nicht mehr um das Lied. Dann hat er das so gesagt, weil ich hatte die Darstellung von ihm immer nur so gesehen, dass er das eigentlich so ganz, vielleicht war das jetzt schon seine politische Wakante 2, dass er das so versteht und schön findet, dass das irgendwie jetzt alle so machen und sollen sie doch machen, aber er selber würde da jetzt sich auch nicht weiter betätigen. Das scheint ja jetzt auch schon nicht mehr so. Richtig. Also mittlerweile umarmt er es einfach, das ganze Ding, und macht da auch, glaube ich, richtig also Geld mit. Mittlerweile werden seine Platten mitgenommen. Er ist ja dann auch, glaube ich, bei dem MTV Lifetime-Award oder irgendwie so was aus dem Internet heraus natürlich vorgeschlagen und ich weiß nicht, hat er dann diesen Preis eigentlich auch bekommen oder wurde er dann disqualifiziert? Also er ist dann gewählt worden als irgendwie bester Künstler aller Zeiten oder sowas und hat diesen Preis auch bekommen, aber er ist dann nicht in dieser Show aufgetreten. Dafür wurde dann halt dieses Lied angespielt und dann meinten diese MTV-Moderatoren dann auch ha ha, ihr seid jetzt gerickrollt. Also das war dann schon Mainstream, dieses Meme. Vor allem das staunende Publikum, was wahrscheinlich in dem Moment noch gar nicht so genau wusste, was eigentlich Sache war, oder? Ist es schon so weit? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie weit es so weit ist. Ich weiß es auch nicht. Also ich weiß, dass dieser Effekt von wegen, dass Leute sich dann auf den Schlips getreten fühlen, den gibt es halt auch noch mal woanders. Also der Moderator von dieser Show, Pimp My Right, Xzibit hat man am Anfang genannt, ist seit kurzem auf Twitter. Und einer seiner ersten Tweets war halt, ey, kann das ja mal endlich aufhören mit diesem Scheiß, I heard you like, so und so weiter. Also er war da richtig angefressen, weil er dachte, es geht darum, ihn zu verarschen. Vorspulen, paar Tage später meinte er, ich habe mir das jetzt im Internet so angeguckt, einiges davon ist echt lustig, ich versuche auch mal.
Was?
Und fing da halt auch an, nach diesem Schema irgendwie Witze zu machen. Es ist schön, wenn die Leute anfangen, auf einmal das Internet zu verstehen. Richtig, richtig, richtig.
Das ist halt ein Meme und das hat halt überhaupt nichts mehr zu tun mit der Person, bei der sie dieses Meme verursacht hat. Und man hat ja viele Meme, die auch gar nicht unbedingt, also wenn beispielsweise das Star Wars Kit oder so, das sind ja so Fälle, da kann man nicht unbedingt sagen, dass jemand willentlich irgendwie was von sich verbreitet haben wollte. Aber das verselbstfindigt sich halt, wird sehr populär und das kann durchaus auch der Person zum Faden geraten. Aber es ist sozusagen, dieser Meme-Struktur ist das völlig egal, wem sie nutzt, ob sie den Ohrheber beispielsweise nutzt.
Und Star Wars Kit ist dieser kleine Junge, der so mit diesem Stab versucht, so ganz toll...
Ein kleiner, etwas korpulenter Junge und man hat sich darüber lustig gemacht, dass er da halt irgendwie ein Jedi-Ritter gespielt hat. Und beispielsweise bei Rick Astley sieht man das halt auch. Da ist es halt völlig egal, ob das Video, an einem bestimmten Punkt ist es halt völlig egal, war das Video mal gut, warum war das so beliebt oder so. Sondern das dient dann einfach nur noch, das ist einfach ein Netztext, der als Netztext funktioniert, der auch als Netztext wieder zurückgetragen wird. Und in dem Moment wird er dann auch bei den MTV Movie Awards dann halt, muss er eigentlich nur noch gewürdigt werden als Netztext. Und man kann das eigentlich nicht mehr in dieses Narrativ. Wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie eine Musikkultur-Gefichte und wir haben jetzt plötzlich festgestellt, dass da ein Werk, was in den 80ern immer noch populär ist, sondern das ist einfach so die kulturelle Logik aus dem Netz macht eine Invasion zurück in den außer Internet Mainstream und eignet sich ihn so an und halt zu den eigenen Spielbedingungen. Das ist eigentlich so das Spannende daran.
Ja, und sagt dann halt irgendwie, keine Angst, wir sind aus dem Internet. Und ja, wirklich, als Musikstück kann man das gar nicht mehr wahrnehmen. Mittlerweile ist es bei mir so, wenn ich halt dieses, es fängt halt an mit so einem verzerrten Trommelwirbel, wenn ich das höre, dann läuft mir schon ein wohliger Schauer den Rücken runter, da muss ich den Rest auch gar nicht mehr hören.
Die Freude an der Wiederholung und am Wiedererkennen, die ganz große Rolle spielt.
Wo ich jetzt immer solche Hintergrund-Experten habe, muss ich jetzt auch selber mal ein paar Internet-Meme hinterfragen, die sich mir noch nicht vollständig erschlossen haben. Was zum Teufel ist mit Ron Paul?
Ja, Ron Paul, also ich hab, ich leg das auch so halb durch, aber er hat halt Präsidentschaftskandidat bei der letzten Wahl.
Also er wollte es werden, also er hat sich beworben innerhalb der Republikanischen Partei, ist ja da auch eher so ein Außenseiter, weil tendenziell eher so demokratisch angehaucht. Nee, nee, nee, das greift er nicht so richtig. Also er vertritt eine politische Richtung, die wir, glaube ich, in Deutschland gar nicht haben, ist so eine Art rechter Anarchismus. Da wollte ich mal irgendwie plakativ sagen, rechtslibertär. Rechtslibertär, genau. Also irgendwie konservativ, aber irgendwie traut er dem Staat nicht oder so. Aha, so FDP oder was? Wie gesagt, fehlt mir einfach echt in Deutschland nichts Etiquates ein.
Das ist vielleicht die Leute, die irgendwie ihren eigenen Staat ausrufen, irgendwie im Floster.
Aber passt halt sehr gut zu dieser ganzen Internet-Kultur. Also auch gerade viele Freiheitskämpfer in der digitalen Welt oder so. Die sind halt auch mit sehr vielen liberalen Themen unterwegs. Das heißt also, Ron Paul war dann halt relativ schnell der Kandidat des Internets, weil er halt auch irgendwie dieses Ganze, ich trau dem Staat nicht, das ist natürlich und das ist alles eine große Verschwörung. Und hier, wir müssen unsere Grundrechte verteidigen, notfalls mit der Waffe in der Hand und so weiter. Diese Attitüde, wie man es auch in manchen Blogs dann irgendwie liest, die hat er halt einfach rübergebracht. Und er war der Kandidat des Internets. Wenn nur im Internet halt abgestimmt wurde, hätte der locker 80 Prozent gekriegt, würde ich mal sagen. Also das wäre völlig klar, dass der dann der Präsident wäre. Oder meins wäre jetzt innerhalb der republikanischen Kandidaten. Nee, insgesamt. Barack Obama war ja nun eben... Na er hat auch sehr, sehr viele Leute angezogen, die gesagt haben, ich habe irgendwie immer auf Seiten der Demokraten gestanden, aber hier Ron Paul ist einfach hier der Freiheitskämpfer an sich und so. Und irgendwann kippte das um, da hat man halt gemerkt, okay, der versammelt auch ganz schön viele Spinner hinter sich. Und vielleicht ist es dann doch strategisch sinnvoller Barack Obama zu unterstützen, blablabla. Aber er war sozusagen halt auch ein Internet-Meme.
Er hatte ja halt seine Groupies, die sehr internetaktiv waren und internetaktive Propaganda gemacht haben, wobei er halt ab einem bestimmten Punkt sich das dann auch verselbstständigt hat. Das heißt, dieses ständige Hereinzwängen von Ron Paul in die öffentliche Sphäre des Internets ist dann halt irgendwann selbst zu einem Gegenstand geworden.
Also dieser Aufruf, doch Ron Paul beim nächsten Mal zu wählen, steht auch schon wieder nur für sich. Man nimmt einfach Ron Paul, ohne dass er jetzt irgendwas Konkretes beigetragen hat, wie irgendeinen Ausruf oder sonst irgendeine anerkennende Sache.
Man macht sich gewissermaßen an irgendeinem Punkt darüber lustig, dass Ron Paul so breit vertreten ist im Netz und macht das dann zu einem eigenständigen Meme, was dann gar nichts mehr zu tun hat mit ich will verhelfen, dass Ron Paul irgendwelche Stimmen bekommt.
Ja, da ist eine echte Diskrepanz. Also er hat halt so eine radikal-liberale Einstellung, die anscheinend im Netz irgendwie sehr weit vertreten ist, aber in der Masse der Gesellschaft halt überhaupt nicht. Und das ist halt echt komisch, weil man halt ins Internet guckt und man denkt irgendwie...
Er ist Piratenpartei.
Ja, Piratenpartei wäre vielleicht ein... ja, ja. Wenn die Piratenpartei sich politisch ein bisschen weiter aufstellen würde, dann würde da Ron Paul auch ganz gut reinpassen. Und was ist mit Rule 34? Tja, die Regeln des Internets oder die Regeln nach denen... Also wir wissen ja alle, dieses Diskussionsforum B auf 4chan und anderen Image-Boards, das hat keine Regeln. Ja. Aber es scheint dann doch Regeln zu geben.
Ja, die ersten zwei Mal wurden ständig gebrochen. Richtig, richtig.
Und da wird uns dann wahrscheinlich die Wut der Internetgemeinde treffen und Anonymous wird irgendwie diesen Podcast millionenfach downloaden und den Server zum Schmelzen bringen. Die erste Regel ist, man redet nicht über B. Die zweite ist, man redet nicht über B. Und in diesem Sinne geht das dann weiter. Du bist ein bisschen wie Fight Club. Es ist Fight Club, ja. Und in diesem Sinne geht das dann weiter. Und diese ersten beiden Regeln werden auch relativ häufig zitiert. Und sehr häufig wird auch die 34. Regel, Rule 34, zitiert, die halt sagt... Und 34B oder 35 sagt dann halt, wenn es noch keinen Porn davon gibt, dann wird Anonymous davon Porn anfertigen. Und also alles, was man sich vorstellen kann, dafür gibt es einen Fetisch im Internet. Und dafür gibt es Leute, die da, was weiß ich, Lego-Steine...
Das läuft dann halt so, man hat einen Imageboard-Thread und der beginnt dann halt mit irgendeinem Bild, meinetwegen von, was weiß ich, Angela Merkel. Und dann schreibt jemand daneben, Rule 34 on that. Und dann kommen dann ganz viele Bilder als Antwort.
Zu der Aufforderung. Richtig. Aber gibt es denn noch zwischen Regel 2 und Regel 34 noch irgendetwas? Also, ich meine, gibt es irgendwo eine Liste dieser Regeln? Es gibt eine Liste bei Enzyklopedia Dramatica und wie alles, was da drin steht, ist die halt entweder wahr oder totaler Quatsch. Okay, die ist also sozusagen dann vielleicht im Nachhinein noch geboren worden. Weil ja, dann diese Rules hat die vor, selber, ich meine, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wir wissen wieder mal nicht, wer es losgetreten hat. Es ist auch irgendwie egal. Auf jeden Fall emanent geworden ist es durch wieder XKCD, was eine interessante Selbstständigung für sich nochmal zu sein scheint, dass es auch in der Lage ist, also dieses Webcomic in der Lage ist, diese Meme auch sozusagen nochmal zu bekräftigen. Also es ist ziemlich sicher, dass der Autor von XKCD halt auch vorhanden unterwegs ist und da halt irgendwie dann sozusagen eine alternative Online-Persönlichkeit auslebt. Weil XKCD ist, naja, das ist halt auch irgendwie ein Comic für, was weiß ich, naturwissenschaftliche Doktoranden. Und manchmal sind ja die Witze halt auf einem mathematisch sehr hohen Niveau und so. Und anscheinend will dieser Typ dann auch mal so seine andere Seite, will auch mal den 14-jährigen Jungen in sich ausleben und treibt sich wohl auch auf Fortune rum. Und da sind dann wohl immer die Schnittstellen, dass er sich da Meme rauspickt aus diesem Internet, wo rast, und das dann halt in sein eher intelligent gemachtes Webcomic reinbringt.
Wo er dann auch als Multiplikator dient. Also das sind dann halt so die Kanäle, über die dann so krankes Zeug aus Fortune in den Mainstream gelangt.
Richtig, richtig, richtig. Ja, vor allem in diesem Comic war ja dann der eigentliche Joke irgendwie so, wenn es irgendwas gibt, dann gibt es dann auch Porn. Und dann ist ja der letzte Satz irgendwie, I'm registering wetriffs.com. Ich glaube, es dauerte nur wenige, keine Ahnung, Stunden, Tage, also nicht lange auf jeden Fall, bis dann dort wirklich dann auch Content ankam. Und wir können uns vorstellen, dann haben die nackte Frauen mit Gitarren in der Hand unter der Dusche oder wo auch immer, sodass sich das dann an der Stelle dann auch wieder los tritt und verselbstständigt.
Das ist dann Rule 34 so ein Beispiel für diese Geste im Internet. Das ist so eine Maschine, ich sage der Maschine irgendwas, irgendeine Idee und diese Idee wird sofort verwirklicht, einfach durch diese Massendynamik im Netz.
Die Echo-Kammer als Medienmetapher sozusagen. Wo kommt das eigentlich her mit dieser Echo-Kammer? Ist das auch ein Meme? So ein intellektuellen Meme vielleicht, ja. Erklär mal, ich habe das noch nie verstanden. Na, in der Echo-Kammer werden halt alle Geräusche verstärkt und prasseln wieder auf dich ein. So ist es in der Blogosphere oder im Imageboard oder so. Du schmeißt irgendwas rein, es kommt wieder zurück und es wird dann wieder aufbereitet und kommt wieder zurück und so weiter.
Und nicht auf die Weise, eventuell, wie du es gerne hättest.
Ja, gibt's denn noch, fallen euch noch ein paar? Wir haben hier noch andere Meme ein, die jetzt noch unbedingt mal erläutert werden müssten, die wir jetzt bisher vergessen haben.
Da gibt es glaube ich diese Seite, List of Internet Phenomena, die ist glaube ich, die funktionieren doch am ehesten in der Wikipedia in der Englischsprache als ein Memeverzeichnis.
Aber selbst da sind eigentlich nur die Mainstream-Memes drin. Wenn es an der Wikipedia steht, ist es schon wieder...
Also es gibt halt, man könnte jetzt natürlich endlos Fortran-Meme beschreiben, wobei die meisten halt wirklich auf Ebene von Bildern funktionieren. Vielleicht ist es ganz hilfreich stattdessen zu sagen, was es halt noch so gibt. Also es gibt beispielsweise, worüber man unbedingt noch sprechen sollte, diese Seite YTMND, You're the man-dog now. Die funktioniert wie... You're the man-dog now, genau. Die funktioniert ähnlich wie beispielsweise andere Memegeneratoren, wie beispielsweise auch YouTube, so, dass man dort Inhalte reinstellt. Und diese Inhalte können wiederum aufgegriffen, vervielfältigt und verändert werden. Wobei dort das Format im Grunde eine Webseite ist, die mindestens besteht aus einem Bild, und die aber vor allem weiter bestehen kann aus Animation, vor allem aus Flash-Animation und aus dazu folgenden Tonspuren. Und diese Seiten werden halt, die sind sozusagen user-generated. Jeder kann da so eine Seite reinstellen und sie generieren, das heißt, er stellt dann meinetwegen, er packt dann irgendwie ein Bild rein, denkt sich dazu eine Tondatei aus, die zu diesem Bild abgespielt werden muss, in einer Endlosschleife, er stellt vielleicht auch einfach statt einem Bild eine Animation rein, die in einer Endlosschleife abgespielt wird. Und dieses Format wird dann halt zuverwendet. Leute sehen da so eine Animation beispielsweise und ziehen die sich und machen daraus eine Variation, die sie dann halt leicht verändern. Und auf diese Weise werden dann ständig bestimmte Formen durchdekliniert. Meinetwegen irgendwie ein Videoclip, wo jemand etwas sagt, wird dann halt ständig vervielfältigt, sodass dann irgendjemand das GIF manipuliert, indem man da noch ein paar Sachen reinzeichnet, oder halt, dass halt irgendwie eine Tonspur verändert wird. Und auf diese Weise entstehen dann ganz, ganz, ganz viele Seiten, die mit solchen Seiten verwandt sind, die irgendeine Bewegung, irgendeine Geste, irgendeinen Witz halt durchdeklinieren. Und das halt auch in einer sehr, sehr hohen Frequenz. Und ja, das ist beispielsweise eine Quelle für Meme, die dann wiederum repliziert werden bei sowas wie YouTube, wo es dann halt so Kompilationen gibt, der der besten YTMND-Meme, also quasi, wo man dann halt GIF-Animationen aneinander pappt, die man dann sich da anschauen kann. Also eigentlich ist es wahrscheinlich sinnvoller, von solchen Seiten, die eine Infrastruktur zur Verfügung stellen, in der Meme entstehen können, zu reden, als jetzt zu schauen, was gibt es jetzt einzelne konkrete Meme.
Was hier auf dieser von dir gerade empfohlenen Seite noch zu finden ist, Liste auf Internet-Phenonima, ist, das werden wir fast entfallen, The Blair Witch Project. Erinnert euch da noch dran? An diesen Film, der ja tatsächlich eigentlich auch so, der erste Film war, wenn ich mich so richtig entsinne, der so durch das Netz überhaupt Popularität erlangt hat. Besteuert auch, versucht, also als Marketingkampagne aufgezogen, dass man immer wieder kleine Netzschnipsel reingestellt hat und dann gesagt hat, hier, was ist das eigentlich? Und die Leute haben angefangen im Netz zu diskutieren, was ist das für ein Film? Ist das echt? Ist das eine Dokumentation? Ist das ein Spielfilm? Läuft heutzutage unter dem Begriff Virales Marketing? Kann ich nur sagen, irgendwie, sagt das mal allen euren Freunden weiter. Virales Marketing funktioniert nicht. Das ist eine nervige, kommerzialisierte Form der Meme. In der Tat, ja. Es gibt richtig Agenturen, die sich auf Virales Marketing, auf Gerüchte verbreiten, spezialisieren und dadurch versuchen, dann irgendwelche Produkte zu pushen.
Man versucht quasi künstlich Meme zu erzeugen. Der Grund, warum das nicht so richtig funktioniert, ist, weil man eigentlich nur eins von beiden haben kann. Entweder man hat etwas, worüber man eine Kontrolle hat. Man möchte ein Produkt vermarkten und das Produkt gut dargestellt wird. Man möchte das sehr gut lenken. Aber dann ist es sehr schwierig, daraus etwas zu machen, was sich von selbst mit Eigendynamik verbreitet. Oder man sagt, ich möchte was generieren, was sich mit Eigendynamik verbreitet. Erstens ist es sehr schwierig, überhaupt so etwas zu generieren. Das klappt dann meistens eher nach, ich stelle eine Experimentieranordnung hin, aus der dann 5000 verschiedene Sachen entstehen. Daraus pflanzen sich dann 3-4 Sachen fort, weil sie besonders effektiv sind und der Rest geht unter. Aber selbst wenn man das einmal geschafft hat, dann kann sich das nur verbreiten, wenn man darüber die Kontrolle aufgibt. Das Kontrolle aufgeben bedeutet dann, dass man die eigene Marke, man muss auch hinnehmen, dass die eigene Marke durch den Dreck gezogen wird und irgendwie zusammen montiert wird mit Kinderpornografie und Hakenkreuzen. Wenn man bereit ist, das zu tun, dann könnte das virale Marketing funktionieren.
Wo es natürlich, also die Kraft des Memes, worüber wir die ganze Zeit sprechen, ist natürlich auch ein interessanter Faktor, wenn es um Spiele geht. Ich wollte jetzt ein ganz tolles Beispiel nennen, komme aber verdammt nochmal nicht auf den Namen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es kennt. Ich deute es mal an. Es gab so eine Aktion in den USA, die man leider hier so nicht hat machen können, weil sie öffentliche Telefonzellen genutzt hat, die man ja auch anrufen kann. Und mir wurde das so erzählt, ich habe jetzt verdammt nochmal vergessen, wie dieses Projekt hieß, auf jeden Fall Leute, was weiß ich, jeden Tag fahren sie zur Arbeit, begeben sich an die Bushaltestelle, daneben steht die Telefonzelle und sie klingelt um 7.31 Uhr. Und sie klingelt und sie klingelt und sie klingelt. Und sie klingelt jeden Tag um 7.31 Uhr. So lange, bis du irgendwann mal da stehst, weil du immer derjenige bist, der auch um 7.31 Uhr an dieser Bushaltestelle stehst, und der denkt, nochmal scheiße, ich geh da jetzt mal ran. Das erste Mädel, was das irgendwie so erlebt, geht da ran und bekommt irgendwelche Informationen gesagt. Irgendjemand spricht zu ihr, sagt irgendwas, legt wieder auf. Nichts passiert. Das Ganze wiederholt sich. Und es wiederholt sich aber nicht nur an dieser einen Stelle, sondern es wiederholt sich all over the USA. Überall werden irgendwelche Telefonzellen angerufen und eine bestimmte Information, bestimmte Namen werden genannt und gesagt und das Telefongespräch beendet. Was passiert? Was passiert? Was denkt ihr euch? Na, es ist wahrscheinlich ein sogenanntes ARG, ein Alternate Reality Game. Das heißt also ein Spiel, was quasi wie ein Rollspiel im Netz funktioniert, aber halt auch in die Echtzeit dann rein spielt. Also da gibt es jemanden, der sich ein Szenario überlegt hat und dann gibt es halt das mit einer ARG-Szene sogenannte Rabbit Holes, wie diese Telefonzelle, wo es dann Eingang in dieses ARG gibt. Und ja, aufgrund dieser Informationen, von wegen mach mal das und das, geh mal da und dahin, dann geht das Spiel dann halt weiter. Genau, die Leute suchen nämlich nach diesen Informationen. Natürlich im Netz finden sich dort, bilden dort sozusagen so gemeinsame Detektivgruppen, um verdammt nochmal diesem Mysterium auf die Spur zu kommen, was in dem Sinne keins ist. Seht ihr da auch so Memekräfte am Werk?
Also ich glaube, das funktioniert wahrscheinlich dann schon eher ein bisschen in der Struktur, in der auch Internet-Meme funktionieren, als jetzt dieses virale Marketing-Nachricht. Ich stelle jetzt einen YouTube-Clip rein und hoffe jetzt, dass er sich vervielfältigt, weil es halt schon mehr damit rechnet, dass Leute sich das selbst zusammensuchen und selbst zusammen organisieren. Wobei das natürlich, damit das dann richtig spannende Effekte ergibt, eigentlich auch erfordert, dass man halt nicht irgendwie einen klaren Pfad vorgibt, nachdem sich das entwickeln muss und dann irgendwie nur die zulässt, die diesem klaren Pfad folgen, sondern dem Ganzen durchaus erlaubt, dass es eine Eigendynamik entwickelt.
Also klar, das wird eingesetzt und die erste Firma, die das wirklich für ein Produkt eingesetzt hat, war die Firma Microsoft. Die haben in ihrer Spieleabteilung einfach mal experimentell mit sogenannten großen Spielen, mit alternativen Realitätsspielen halt gearbeitet und da gab es eine Kampagne I like bees, ich mag Bien, wo dann halt in Filmen immer so ein Hinweis auf diese Kampagne gezeigt wurde und am Schluss kam raus, es geht um die Xbox. Nachdem das ganze Puzzle entwirrt worden ist. In Deutschland ist das eher noch so ein bisschen, na ja, also da gab es irgendwie so vereinzelte Versuche irgendwelchen Bloggern Zeug zu schicken und das sollte dann halt auch ein Rätselspiel sein und die Leute sollten darüber bloggen und am Schluss wäre dann rausgekommen, dass es für irgendwie ein Computerspiel oder so die Marketing-Kampagne war. Nachdem man dann rausgefunden hat, wer diese mysteriöse Herr ist, der da irgendwie gerade in Gefahr ist und so weiter. Das ist irgendwie ja von der Blogger-Szene in Deutschland nicht so richtig gut angenommen worden und ich glaube halt auch wirklich, man kann es nur bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt steuern, weil die gleichen Leute, die halt auch kreativ sind, bloggen, Sachen ins Netz reinstellen oder so, die können das halt auch wirklich komplett umdrehen und dann einfach sich ein Spiel draus machen, herauszufinden, für wen werde ich jetzt eigentlich gerade benutzt, was steckt denn da für eine Kampagne dahinter und was ist der Sinn des Spiels und wo sitzen die Spielmacher und so.
Das ist dann vielleicht auch der Punkt, wo, um auf die Frage von vorhin nach der Intelligenz zurückzukommen, wo halt wirklich so eine Art kulturelle Intelligenz entsteht, ist halt wirklich aus diesem Sachenverselbstständigen sich gegenüber dem, man versucht irgendwie was zu steuern und was reinzustellen, weil man erwartet, dass Leute das so und so rezipieren und kulturell weitertragen, ist halt der Punkt, wo eine eigene Intelligenz entsteht, derjenige, wo man eben das nicht mehr unter Kontrolle bringen kann und sich dieses kulturelle Ding, was man da reingeworfen hat, halt verselbstständigt, seine eigenen Dynamiken entfaltet und Leute halt dazu bringt, mit sich was anzustellen, was man halt eigentlich nicht erwartet hat oder steuern wollte.
Auf jeden Fall werden wir noch so einige Internet-Meme, glaube ich, sicher entwickeln sehen. Also, der Punkt ist schon interessant. Kann man mit Memen irgendwie Geld machen? Ist das halt nur Zeitverschwendung oder kommt da was Sinnvolles raus?
Da kann man damit Politik machen.
Kann man damit Politik machen, kann man da irgendwie Geld oder Macht mit gewinnen? Und auf der Republika war halt für mich so ein Erlebnis, als ich diesen Mut von Forjaan hab reden hören, der hat seit fünf, sechs Jahren nichts anderes gemacht, außer sein Image-Sport zu betreiben. Der hat sonst nichts in der Hand. Er hat irgendwie das bekannteste Image-Sport in der westlichen Welt und ist Quelle all dieser wunderbarer oder schrecklicher Meme wie Loycats, wo eine ganze Firma dahinter steckt, Failblock, wo eine ganze, also die gleiche Firma wie Loycats, die machen alle Kohle. Er selber finanziert sich hauptsächlich wohl irgendwie dadurch, dass seine Eltern ihn unterstützen. Und für ihn kommt da irgendwie nichts mehr rund. Also er versucht, er versuchte da immer irgendwie wieder Anzeigen auf 4chan zu schalten, aber dann sagen die Anzeigen-Kunden irgendwie, das ist so ein Umfeld, da möchten wir nicht gerne so unsere Produkte präsentiert haben.
Er hat so viel kulturelle Macht wie vielleicht so früher in der Massenmedien-Gesellschaft vielleicht so die größten Superstars vielleicht gehabt hätten, aber es bringt ihm überhaupt nichts nach so klassischen Begriffen wie Geld oder Macht.
Und er ist, also das war auch wahrscheinlich der Grund, warum er jetzt in Berlin war. Er reist halt durch die Welt und versucht irgendwie herauszufinden, ob er mit dieser Macht, die er kulturell hat, irgendwie mal seinen Lebensunterhalt bestreiten kann. Aber es gelingt im Moment noch gar nicht. Auch das ist nicht steuerbar. Warum lässt das nicht einfach sein? Macht was anderes.
Weil die Meme-Intelligenz ihn angesteckt hat und ihn zu einem ausführenden Sklaven gemacht hat, der sie am Leben erhält.
Genau. Er ist schon ein eigenes Meme. Mut, der die Welt anführt und uns neuen Wahnsinn zeigt.
Es gab ja öfter diese Gefichte, dass irgendwie Time oder so irgendwie ihre Liste der 100 einflussreichsten Leute oder so. Und da hat dann irgendwie so Fortran ihn so auf Nummer 1 katapultiert.
Es ging noch weiter. Es ging noch weiter. Sie haben natürlich Mut auf Nummer 1 gewählt. Klar. Völlig logisch. Also was anderes hätte man auch nicht erwartet. Sie haben dann alle anderen Leute ab Platz 2 bis 50 so von der Wahl manipuliert und angeordnet, dass man von oben nach unten gelesen einen Satz aus einem Mem aus Fortran hinkriegt.
Ein Akrostikon.
Ja, also es ging um Kuchen. Überhaupt ein wichtiges Mem. Weil man möchte nicht wirklich wissen, was sich hinter diesem Kuchen versteckt. Aber sie haben wirklich einen Satz da rein gewotet in die Top 100-Liste. Und das ist schon Präzisionshacking, würde ich mal sagen. Das ist wirklich unglaublich.
Also man hat ja wirklich eine kulturelle Intelligenz, die die alte kulturelle Welt hackt und völlig ihre eigenen Logik unterzwingt.
Ja, und vor allem das ist interessant. Also es ist so eine Intelligenz der Masse, die aber zielgerichtet ist. Es gibt ja auch diese Intelligenz der Masse. Was weiß ich, du hast so ein riesiges Glas voll mit Murmeln und du sollst schätzen, wie viele Murmeln da drin sind. Und tatsächlich lässt sich halt belegen, wenn da jetzt tausend Leute vorbeigehen und jeder schätzt irgendwas, und die können auch teilweise riesige Ausreiße haben, dass die am Schluss tatsächlich irgendwie mehr oder weniger genau auf die Zahl Murmeln kommen. Nur, dass keiner von denen weiß, was sie tun eigentlich. Also klar, sie wissen was sie tun. Weil sie kein Internet haben, wo das alles dann zusammen gegossen wird. Das ist halt der große kulturelle Unterschied. Aber was ich sagen will, ist, offensichtlich gibt es schon auch eine Intelligenz der Masse, die auch tatsächlich koordiniert was bewegen kann. Anonymous versus Scientology-Geschichte. Gut, da kann man jetzt gespaltener Meinung darüber sein, ob es wirklich was bewegt hat. Weil Scientology ist natürlich immer noch da und liegt nicht in tausend Scherben vor uns. Aber vielleicht sind wir ja auch erst am Anfang. Also vielleicht sind diese Internet-Meme jetzt quasi die Beta-Version einer Kulturintelligenz der Masse, die tatsächlich einen Einfluss auf die reale Gesellschaft ausübt, den wir jetzt noch gar nicht abschätzen können. Oder die reale Gesellschaft letztendlich ersetzen wird.
Aber da gibt es halt Leute, die da richtig auch dagegen pochen und sagen, das ist ja eigentlich ziemlich gruselig, weil wir haben plötzlich so eine neue Intelligenz, die Feinbar ziemlich mächtig ist, die aber gar nichts mehr mit unseren Maß stehend, nachdem wir als Menschen, als Individuen die Welt versuchen zu ordnen und irgendwie unter unserer Kontrolle zu kriegen, zu tun ist und zu tun hat und nicht mehr unbedingt unsere Interessen in Feinbar teilt. Das sieht man halt daran, dass Memes sich replizieren und man nicht so genau sagen kann, die verbreiten sich jetzt, weil Menschen ja irgendwie das und das wollen, sondern die verbreiten sich offenbar, indem sie irgendwelche Sachen ansprechen, die jetzt nicht beispielsweise der Ethik unserer Gesellschaft entsprechen. Und da gibt es halt, das lässt sich auch von bis zu Dawkins zurückverfolgen, da ist dann immer in dieser Formulierung diese Meme, das sind irgendwie machtvolle kulturelle Strukturen, die nicht einfach nur uns darstellen, sondern die auch irgendwie uns unter Kontrolle bringen können und die uns sozusagen auch dazu bringen können, beispielsweise Dinge zu machen, von denen wir gar nicht wissen, warum wir sie machen. Und ist das nicht eigentlich sogar eine Gefahr, gegen die wir irgendwie uns sträuben müssten?
Ist das jetzt wieder diese frankensteinsche Angst, das Zauberlehrling, das Monster, was wir schufen?
Genau, das war auch eine westliche Krankheit. Also was ich da sehr empfehlen kann, ist der TED-Talk von Susan Blackmore, die auch Memeforferin ist und die davor warnt, die Teams, das sind die Technological Memes, die könnten uns quasi übernehmen und könnten sich quasi verselbstständigen und brauchen dann irgendwann die Menschen gar nicht mehr, um sich zu replizieren. Und wenn sie uns nicht mehr brauchen, dann faffen sie uns quasi ab, weil wir ja nur noch irgendwie Ressourcenverwender sind.
Was Roboter Herrschaft, Terminator oder was? Oder so ein bisschen wie bei Alien, dem Film, wo es erst Spaghetti gibt und dann ja, diese Szene, wo sich halt irgendwelche Aliens in Menschen halt irgendwie reinfressen und so weiter.
Also immer die Biologie für Metapher. Das sind auch nur Parasiten, die uns jetzt irgendwie zwar sehr cool vorkommen, aber das liegt nur daran, weil sie sich darauf optimiert haben, uns zu gefallen für ihren eigenen Vorteil. Irgendwann werden die Katzen uns beherrschen.
Du meinst, die Kätzchen, die immer bei diesen ganzen selbst ausgerufenen Weltdiktatoren im Arm vor sich hinporren, sind die eigentlichen Warenherrscher?
Das ist ja ein sehr populäres Meme halt. Vielleicht ist in diesem Meme sogar was dran. Es gab auch mal jemand, der behauptet, wenn die Roboterintelligenz die Menschheit übernimmt, dann wird sie verfeindlich in Lolcat-Sprache sprechen, weil sie damit uns viel besser kontrollieren kann.
Das heißt, am Ende stehen sie wirklich vor uns und sagen, all your base are belong to us.
Niedlichkeit ist ja etwas, was wunderbar unsere Kritikfähigkeit herab setzt, genauso wie das dann so irgendwie Religion tut.
Das heißt dann doch nicht mehr Frankenstein, nicht mehr diese hässlichen, zusammengenähten Monstertypen, sondern eigentlich total putzige kleine Wesen, so wie bei Monty Python irgendwie dieses kleine Kaninchen, was die ganzen Ritter dann wegschlachtet.
Genau, weil es uns Spaß macht, uns dem zu beugen.
Also wir sitzen sozusagen lachend vor dem Internet und kichern über putzige kleine Kaninchen und Katzen, die eigentlich schon planen, uns alle zu kontrollieren und zu übernehmen.
Genau.
Und die Menschheit auszurotten.
Na ist doch super. Dann haben wir ja die Sache jetzt auch ausreichend erforscht mit diesen Worten. Denke ich, können wir die Sache zum Abschluss bringen, oder haben wir noch irgendwas ganz Kluges vergessen, was wir unbedingt noch mal erwähnen mussten? Hier wird allgemein mit dem Kopf geschüttet.
Ins Internet gucken, da findet man ganz viel.
Genau, schaut mal ins Internet. Es gibt da noch sehr viel mehr schlimme Sachen. Ihr könnt glücklich sein, wenn ihr die Sendung gehört habt und ich nicht den Podcast-Link direkt auf Rick Astley gelenkt habe. Dann sage ich erstmal Danke, Christian und Jens, super, für die tolle Runde. Jetzt haben wir hier über zwei Stunden mitgefüllt mit Internet-Memen und dem Versuch, einem Phänomen, einem weitverbreiteten ein bisschen auf die Fläche zu kommen. Ich hoffe, das ist uns ein wenig gelungen. Ihr hattet auch Spaß dabei. Ich bin begierig auch auf euer Feedback, auf unseren Blog, blog.chaosradio.cc.de, wie gewohnt, oder Mail, wenn es ganz wichtig und geheim ist. Und ja, dann hoffen wir, dass wir uns bald wieder hören, hier bei Chaosradio Express.